Welcome back!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, Minkie!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi!
Hi, hi, hi!
Today we plan on beating the game, so I have quite a bit to go.
But I want to beat it.
I want to beat it today.
We will definitely do some secret theater.
Especially at least watch the new ones.
And I would like to do some snake versus monkey.
People monkey.
But I guess that depends on how long it takes me to beat.
Welcome back to membership.
Thank you!
Thanks for the early stream.
Watch the fantastic reality archive and your performance is so good.
Thank you!
Are you excited to play Snake's Nightmare minigame?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I was just thinking!
I was like, oh my gosh, wait!
When I saw...
Grasni-Grad torture room, I was like, wait!
I know what we're about to do!
And then also...
Also, also, also, also, also, also, also...
I'm so excited.
sorry I had a I had a thought and then I lost it no hold hold on oh this is this is very this is so those who don't know the the nightmare game oh my gosh it was in the original and now it's in this and they redid it with platinum so I wonder what it will feel like if it'll feel like
And, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and I also realized, oh my gosh, we still have one Cobra unit person to go through.
Which I've also been so excited about.
We have quite, actually quite a bit left of the game.
So it will probably be a longer stream.
But that's okay.
More Metal Gear.
Burley, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
I'm trying to keep the MGS series spoiler free.
Oh!
The save file is also red just like on the PS2.
Where?
Am I missing?
Iron cog hard 3.
Python snacker.
Yep, that's what we're playing today.
More and more of our metal gear!
Exactly!
On the load.
Oh my gosh!
It is!
I guess we have to load this one then instead of the auto-save, huh?
If I had just pressed continue.
What?
It actually is!
That's so cool.
Me even hiking up a mountain.
What a hill.
Oh my gosh.
This is going to be a lot of fun because there's a lot of really fun stuff we have left to do.
So let's just not waste any time.
Let's just get into it, huh?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Uh, my game.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, gosh.
Nightmare game.
Ah, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
No.
Oh, my God.
No way.
Hold on.
One moment, please.
Uh, uh, game, uh, specific, uh, nightmare.
Uh?
Oh my
gosh.
Wait.
This is crazy.
It feels like.
It feels like how, you know, an MGS4, when you switch to playing one in the dream.
It feels just like that.
That's so crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Guy Savage.
Whoa.
Wow.
Devil May solid.
It looked...
Wait, I don't remember it starting outside.
I don't remember the Guy Savage sequence very well, though.
I'll be honest.
Do I have to parry in this?
Please say no.
Oh, they're strong.
Oh!
What's happening?
Let's go.
How's the audio, by the way?
It's good?
Okay, thank you.
Quiet.
The game itself seems a little quiet.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Arnar, we're surrounded.
Clear.
Oh, okay.
Just throw me in there.
Throw me in, boss.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm just button-mashing.
This is so insane.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going insane.
This is so cool.
Hey.
No.
Oh, he's still up?
Oh, there we go.
I thought, yeah, I remember Guy Savage being indoors.
The blood moon.
Hot dog indeed!
Vampire!
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
This is so cool!
Wait, I can't believe!
Oh.
Where is he?
Oh!
Oh, there he is.
Oh my gosh.
Crazy, crazy.
The music even?
Like, what the hell?
Oh, where'd he go?
Oh, more Zombos.
Even in Metal Gear, I play Zombo game.
Oh, I don't think I got him.
Oh, yes, I did.
Okay, good.
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, come on.
There we go.
Whoa, this is really nice when he gets surrounded.
Oh, look, come here.
Oh, my gosh.
There's so many of them!
Spin!
This is so crazy.
I can't get over how crazy this is.
Crazy this is.
Oh.
Why so much effort?
I mean, it's awesome.
I just, like, what the heck?
How long does it go for?
I wonder!
What's happening?
Oh my god.
Oh no!
He's here too!
Oh my god.
Ah!
We're gonna spin?
Spin?
We're gonna- Oh gosh!
Oh gosh!
Did I do it?
Spin to win!
Oh, I savage.
Huh?
Oh, the game is back!
Fine.
Let me pull up metal...
Oh, that's back.
This is good.
We're fine.
Good morning, Snake!
Wow!
They completely redid it.
Like, it didn't look at all like how it was before.
Oh!
Hello!
Thank you!
There's so much food here!
Hi!
I had a dream where I was in a classroom with fellow wisps and you were the teacher.
You like blood-borne, don't you?
Oh wait, wrong- wait, there we go.
Let's get- let's get out.
This transmitter!
Wait, no.
I want to keep the transmitter.
I'm gonna keep the transmitter in.
We're gonna keep that in.
Yeah, we're gonna keep it in.
That guy was pretty savage.
For those who don't know, so in the original game, not in the HD collection, there was a...
There was a...
A dream sequence like that that you could unlock.
With, uh...
With...
Um, guys, where it had that, like, kind of demo of that game.
And just for this, they remade it, which is just so crazy.
Ronan, thank you!
Welcome back!
Perhaps in another life where Snake is in a legendary soldier, he could have been a really good game developer.
That's so cool.
That's so cool!
Oh my gosh!
Um, and it's...
Oh, we could fork it?
Um...
Oh, no, wait, I don't have my knife.
Wait, can I get it out with the fork?
Oh, no way!
We got it out with the fork!
That's so good.
Why are you so freaky?
Because I'm a ghost.
Wait.
Huh?
Time to eat!
Thank you!
Okay, now...
Let's give him...
the bat.
Oh, oops, hold on.
I can't aim.
I can't aim at all.
Wait, okay, there we go.
Huh?
It's gonna be its own game.
What?
You don't want this?
I believe that's how it was.
Oh, shoot.
I don't remember what the codec was.
Was it yummy?
I guess it was good.
Hello, Rat.
I hear them both.
I hear...
Go, go!
In one side and...
And...
And the other side.
Come here, Rat.
We're eating.
We're eating good.
What else does he want?
Oh, this one's spoiled.
Okay, this is good.
This is good.
144.75.
Okay, cool.
Wait, we'll wait.
I hear him over there, and then I hear...
Wait, let me make sure...
Okay, my headphones are on correctly.
Just make it sure.
You want that?
It's yours!
You can hear the flies.
At least Snake's nightmare was nowhere near as horrible Siggins.
Free food!
Got our single-action army.
I guess I should have given him any of the spoiled stuff, huh?
Beep.
Oh,
wow.
You can see out the window and everything.
You're welcome.
guys how do i oh this is rotten oh sorry oh my stomach thank you brother
forgot to ask um oh snake you don't look so good Oh, his eyeball.
Oh, snake, it all looks so good.
I forgot to ask, how do I get the cutscene with Johnny?
I don't remember.
Gosh, look at this.
This is...
Oh my gosh.
Honestly, it looks better than I thought with all that he went through.
Three food?
Okay, okay.
Well, three food.
Okay, that's what I thought.
So what?
We just have to give him one more, no?
Or three good meals.
It's coming out!
Here it come!
Still going.
I didn't think that was possible.
That's a record.
Well, this is even flush.
It's not the second flush.
We'll wait for him to give us more food then.
I want to be able to get the cute little cutscene.
It's so cute.
Yeah, but fake death points.
pill now too.
Sort of like solid snakes.
Catch up.
Skip.
No.
There's a couple ways he can get out.
Hey, hey!
Hey, Smelly!
Did you wash your hands?
Of course he don't look good, Minto.
He's missing an eye.
Hey!
I hope that cure goes away.
I hope they like...
I don't want it to just sit there the whole time, you know.
King of the poop What does that mean?
Hey!
I'm hungry!
Time to eat?
Ciao time!
What you give me?
Oh, frog!
Let's go!
Oh, here it is.
I don't, uh, you have it.
Huh?
He's so cute.
Well, it's your loss.
It's for you, buddy!
Quiet down there, will ya?
It's actually so stupid.
He's actually the dumbest guy ever to exist.
Don't make fun of him?
What are you doing?
Instead of faking being sick for the guard snake, it's the guard sick instead.
Exactly!
Shut up in there, will ya?
Huh?
Look at why?
What are you looking for?
It's just me!
He is, but he's endearing.
Don't get me wrong, I love the guy so much.
Huh?
Give me more food.
Don't get fed, you know.
Oh!
I'm sorry, Papa!
Papa, please!
Papa, feed me!
Kiss your feet, Papa!
What are you even looking for in here?
There's a whole lot of nothing, okay, buddy?
He isn't that after all.
He is.
We know that.
Oh?
Child time!
He's so sleepy.
Look at that.
The right side is a little...
a little messed up.
My stomach!
Again?
Oh, I can't hold it anymore.
The way he runs is so...
Hold on!
Hold it!
How do I...
Round two?
The waddle.
I know.
At least you only hear him.
You know?
Poor Johnny.
His whole family lineage has bathroom issues.
I know.
Oh.
Just one flash.
Ciao time.
Go get my food, please.
depth perception sorry it's so loud I turned it up so he could hear him I felt like bless you snakes the reason he and his descendants have IBS I don't think it's our fault
heredity is IBS like a like is it a genetic thing is it a dominant gene Oh, chow time!
Please, sir, I want...
Please, sir, can I have some more?
Oh, fish this time!
Wow, feeding us good.
Oh, wait.
Johnny, hold on.
Wait, Johnny, one moment.
I didn't mean to...
Hold on.
There you go.
Keep being epic.
Thank you!
Thanks, man.
You're welcome.
Eat up.
You have anything to say to me?
Yes!
Hey, you're not such a bad guy after all.
I, uh, I guess not all Americans are dogs.
You mean it?
Yeah!
you mean it you know before the war started I used to live in America I even had a wife and a kid you must be pretty lonely I could I could fix that I am pretty lonely really lonely why is he dragging his kids name say it Johnny Johnny nice ring to it really you like it well if you say so I'll I'll believe you.
So cute.
Actually, my name is Johnny too.
He's so cute.
All the firstborn sons in my family are called Johnny.
Johnny.
My dad's a Johnny.
And my son's son will probably be a Johnny too.
He will be.
No, clan of Johnny's.
Why do we have a cold war anyway?
MGS4 Johnny under that under that our two countries used to be such good friends yeah I hear you I just want to see my family again Johnny must be rough yeah not as rough as you have it though yeah that's true here I filter them from your when the Colonel wasn't looking oh thank you it's the least I can do my smokes oh I've winked but you couldn't tell well kiss him don't suppose you could let me out of here huh I can't do that I can't do that don't you go getting any funny ideas if you try to escape i'll have to shoot you okay oh i'm fine i'm fine i've said too much it was worth asking i gotta go don't be all don't be all like tundere now what kind of parents name someone johnny too
yay we got our cigarette spray oh wait was it always did they refill it nice Okay, wait, if we make some noise, if what, 1, 44, 75?
Come look in here!
Come look in here.
Hey, come here.
Wait, come here.
Come here.
Too far away.
Damn it.
Oh, wait.
Are you close enough now?
Are you close?
Are you close enough?
No?
No!
No, well, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey!
I'm doing all sorts of mischief in here.
Here we go, here we go.
Oh, hello.
What's all that noise?
What are you doing?
Nothing.
I'm having a smoke.
Come look in here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
There we go.
Wait, now.
Please, I don't want to waste all these.
There we go.
Nice.
Wait, not the cure.
My bad.
Shoot.
I can't remember how to just get to regular codec.
Why am I so stupid?
I don't remember how to open up the codec menu.
Wait, one second.
I don't remember what the...
Hmm.
Down D-pad.
I'm doing it.
on that it's not it's not opening anything you guys oh i have to hold it ah it's because i was pressing up for cure and you don't have to hold that what happened major what year is this beg your pardon where am i it's 1964 you're in a cell in groznygrad what did they do snake make you drink an entire keg of vodka no maybe you know i hear they've got 98 proof vodka We'll call everybody,
don't worry.
Back in England, we don't call stuff like that fine spirit.
We call it sulfuric acid.
Imagine, if you will, your internal organs being slowly eaten away as smoke pours out of your mouth.
Really, Snake, you shouldn't be touching that.
Was it a dream?
A dream?
Well, how nice.
And here I thought I sat up all night worrying about you for nothing.
It was almost real.
I was holding this sword in my hand.
Snake, are you okay?
You're not going loony.
on me are you not at all i'll make it back no matter how much of that sulfuric acid they make me drink good show i'm sure you'll find a way out of there yeah dream a little dream of your own while you wait for word from me what a strange way to put that snake what happened what do you think are you not feeling well no i'm feeling fine i had the most amazing dream thanks to you dream about track don't say it the last thing I need is a double feature it was surreal I was being attacked by a horde of weird human-like monsters what's wrong with me it must be a form of persecution complex probably triggered by extreme stress the external stimulus of the room is I've got a different theory I think it was caused by your pillow talk but I didn't I'm sorry snake I didn't know you were that sensitive to it i mean who'd have thought drac sorry that just slipped out i swear come on snake don't be mad at me all right i forgive you really yeah good i'm glad yeah snake there must be a way out of
there don't get discouraged you'll find it i intend to yes snake you okay yeah I had a terrible dream No kidding What happened?
I don't want to think about it There was this monster There were more monsters than Vampires though It's all over when you wake up True He's so cute I know The fact that you can imagine a situation Worst than the one you're in now He lives in Santa Afraid of Dracula Vampires He's so cute Let me tell you about the absolute worst Most sickening nightmare I ever had This isn't one for the kids Okay,
so there's this big pile of crap, right?
It's shaped like a giant tank and it's walking around on two legs going on a rampage and stopping on people and houses and stuff.
And this giant turd is carrying the nastiest missiles you ever saw.
Like whenever it launches one of its turd missiles, whatever it hits, people, trees, buildings, turns into crap.
Poopy gear solid.
My hometown, my old school, my family, my girlfriend, old man John.
everything in that turd's path turned into crap that's pretty sick man good thing was just a dream huh yes that's a good thing you feeling better now yeah good then let's get down to business you see snake people are just turd sacks and they're full of holes fill them up with water and it's got to come out from somewhere okay maybe that was a bad example what I'm trying to say is no matter what the situation there's always a way out don't throw in the towel yet clear your mind think it through assess the situation you'll find a way to escape got it don't let my nightmare come true right not the poopy gear solid no no please wrap it up a lot of folks suspected they could easily replace Guy Savage with something Castlevania.
But it's cool they brought Platinum just for that.
Yeah, right?
So good.
Oh, uh, uh, but, but, but, but.
Uh, tune.
Okay, one.
What?
144.
Got 7.5.
Was it?
I believe?
Okay.
The door has been unlocked.
This is one of my favorite Kodak combos in the entire series.
Oh.
Hello?
I forgot to ask James Mathis about it.
No!
Yeah, I'm out.
Be careful.
In your present state, you're practically naked.
Naked?
You don't have a single decent weapon, and you'll never survive in a battle.
Take some time and pull yourself together.
Okay.
Eva says she's recovered your equipment, so rendezvous with her as soon as possible.
to get your gear back.
Use the escape route Eva set up for you.
Go down into the sewers through the manhole in the northwest section of Krosnigrad.
Start out by exiting the holding cells and heading northwest.
There's dogs over there, you know.
What you got?
Johnny, anything for me?
Oops.
Smoke grenade.
That's very handy.
Anything in here?
No?
Wait, where is Agako?
I hear him.
How am I supposed to shoot him?
How am I supposed to get him, though?
Anything in there?
No?
What's this?
A camera.
Thargo, thanks for the thank you, dude!
Finger guns, yeah.
We'll just, uh...
Oh, there's a...
Oh, uh...
Wait.
Um...
Can I fork him?
I
can't get any closer.
No, the cult does not have any ammo.
Hmm.
It's just out of reach.
It's okay.
I've already missed so many that it's kind of like a...
Not a super huge deal if I...
Miss one, you know?
What's in here?
Wait.
Oh, Tamika.
Oh, whoa.
Wow.
Wee.
Sorry, the more I look, the more I'm wow.
Sorry.
I'm not sorry.
Damn.
Madame!
Okay.
That rod of yours.
This is the other door, right?
Or this goes into...
Oh wait.
Oh no, this is where it all happens.
Wait, is Gakko in there?
No?
Hmm.
Where could he be?
I hear him.
Wait, did I go in here?
Oh.
It would be really messed up if Gakko is in here.
That would be so horrible.
Oh, it's freaky in here.
Okay, we're still fine.
Okie dokie!
I have...
I have a bat I can eat.
I probably should have waited for some more food, maybe.
The fun room.
Well, we'll just eat some rats in the sewer, I guess, or something.
We'll just...
Alright.
I have to find...
I hear someone over there.
Oh my gosh.
We have to find...
Oh, are you kidding me?
No, there was nobody.
Already!
So evil.
Okay.
He doesn't know.
Best would be if Gakko was actually chained off.
That's freaky for real.
Oh my gosh.
I can't change.
I have no camo at all.
This sucks.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Oh, wrong button.
This one.
Oh, does it show the little...
The little passageways?
It doesn't.
I don't remember where it is.
Literally just finished work and started watching this first thing I see is Vinto checking out the models.
Oh, too few!
Johnny drops ramen.
Really?
He's got ramen on him?
And he was holding out on us?
Wait, is he awake?
Nothing?
Never mind.
We're not dealing with...
It's fine.
We don't need it.
We'll get it back.
Oh, gosh.
All right.
They can probably see my breath home.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, that guy.
Let's see.
What do you do?
What are you doing over there, huh, buddy?
Can you kind of stay still for a bit?
I think there's a hole over there.
just have to get oh wow he really just stands there for quite a while okay and then he turns and he does come this way maybe I'll have my cigarette sprayer we'll have the cigarette spray ready with hand okay all right I wish I could hold him up wait I can he doesn't know he doesn't know it's not loaded excuse me please turn around thank you all right so he's gonna walk over there then he's gonna walk back and then we're gonna hold him up we're gonna go freeze freeze wait how long does he stand there okay let's go don't notice me please all
right nice freeze okay hopefully I don't screw this up okay snake freeze yeah he doesn't know he doesn't know get down get down don't shoot me please wiggle wiggle for me wiggle wiggle for me yeah that's what I want wiggle wiggle for me what is this okay oh we actually got some ammo now Let's go?
Are you gonna wiggle wiggle for me again?
That's what I thought.
Oh shoot!
I'm an idiot.
Let's just go this way.
Are they accidentally let go?
Where's the hole?
I found it.
Okay, we're fine now.
Okay, now we can eat.
Come here, little rat.
Where are you?
Let's actually...
Oh.
Oh, I was gonna say, yeah, I do have a gunshot wound.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, I gotta get them.
I'm bleeding.
Oh, bandage.
Okay.
Okay, good.
This might actually be your biggest flub yet.
I was so good.
I'm going the wrong way, aren't I?
Come here.
Come here, little rat.
Okay.
Tasty.
Definitely.
I definitely screwed that up.
I take full responsibility.
I really messed that up pretty bad.
Come in HQ.
This is HQ.
Control here.
I wonder where Gakko is.
I knew that Kedotan was down here, but...
Where am I?
Yeah, I'm so far.
Oh, gosh.
Um...
Might be easier to go back to the other area.
I don't know, actually.
Can't tell which would be faster.
Kedot, Kedot.
Yeah, it might be easier to just go to this area.
There was another door, maybe it would go through the other way.
Oh, how did I miss that up so badly?
It's on this side?
Nothing here?
Uh, I'm here, little rant.
I'm gonna consume you.
No one see?
Okay, no one hears me chomping in the sewers.
Actually, what is this?
It's not really sewers.
It's just...
Okay, we're back where we started.
I don't want to kill anybody, but...
Zero progress.
Could you...
I wish my friend L.
Happy birthday!
L!
Happy, happy birthday!
There should be a turn.
Where?
Nope.
Yeah, let me see, hold on.
That door down there will try and go through.
And then we'll go through down there.
Well, we're going through like extra areas.
Might just be better to brute force it, I wonder.
If I just run...
Like, what?
Stealth?
We don't need it!
Yeah, we're back to where we held the dude up originally.
If I just run...
This isn't a stealth game.
Yeah, exactly.
Stealth is so optional.
I wish I could see No one's here
I hear walking like Oh my god he's right there
He is very close
Oh dang I was gonna say I'm cheating I was gonna use the camera mode to
You can leave now sir You can leave You can leave Let's play Super Robot Wars and you can have borderline, come on.
Reminded me of our ghost made.
Appreciate you.
I just thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I can't tell if he's gone or not.
I'm listening.
He's HQ.
This is HQ.
He's like right there.
Control here.
No problems detected.
Understood.
Return to your position.
Oh my god!
Footsteps.
No, no, that's not exactly, that's not at all what you heard.
Don't do it.
I'm gonna eat your legs.
Yeah, nobody here, dummy.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna eat it.
I'm gonna chow down.
I don't think I wouldn't do it!
I don't want to kill anybody.
I wish this guy would just leave!
I can't hear anymore.
Climb, climb, climb, climb, please.
The door was, uh...
I guess there's somebody over here.
Is there?
Maybe not?
Did I hear kiddo kiddo?
Huh, okay.
What was I hearing then?
We crawl?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you heard someone walking too, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Keep going?
Don't stop going.
I will also keep going and don't stop going.
Bite his boots.
I'm gonna bite him by the booties.
I am going the right way, right?
Oh, I always press the wrong button.
Yeah, we're gonna go through...
We'll go to the...
We'll go through whichever one we can make it to.
Seems like a supreme design oversight to have all these man-sized vents over all of them.
No.
What?
In fact, it's better for the whole team.
What's this?
Disinfecting the bandage.
Okay.
Oh no.
I'm like barely even over there.
Okay
Oh Oh shit.
Oh we're running Ouch we're running snake we're not stopping we're running.
We're running and we're flipping we're flipping around Yep Okay, we're running I didn't see anyone did you guys we're running We're running We're running.
We're running.
I know exactly where to go.
Don't release the dog.
Damn it!
We're fine.
Just keep going, Snake!
We got that!
That was so easy!
Don't ignore the alarms going on up there.
Snake, you're already in the sewers.
Eva, yeah, I just got down here.
I'm coming to meet you now.
The door at the north end is open, right?
Right?
Ah, Snake?
What?
Let me guess.
There's a problem.
Yeah.
What is it this time?
The Colonel found out you escaped.
Oh, I wonder how.
I figured as much.
Yeah, and now all of Grozny Grad is on red alert.
What?
Just my luck.
But once I'm out of the fortress...
You can't get out.
I can't.
When the fortress went on red alert, alert they sealed off the sewers how did they know i'm serious no that means the escape route i laid out is sealed off too so unlucky they just sent a unit out looking it wasn't my fault they discovered i was gone they'll be there any minute now you've got to get out quick oh gosh i hate this part i like this part but i hate it at the same time i should be able to get out by heading straight north book it snake if they find you you're dead okay one moment one moment i have some in me,
I believe.
Um.
Time to wander through the sewers with all these open wounds.
You almost made her cry from having this.
Stop.
What the heck?
I didn't even do anything.
This part is not my favorite.
Oh.
But we shall endure.
Not my favorite.
Many dogs.
But it also has one of my favorite cutscenes.
So you know what?
I will forgive.
Menu.
Oh, my food?
Maybe I will eat.
I only have as a bat.
Nah, well, thank you so much for another 20.
Thank you!
I remember this part, but I don't remember the staircase.
You know, I don't...
I feel like I remember the staircase.
I'm not sure, actually.
Okay.
We gotta, like, crawl...
Oh, wait.
Here's some food.
Lucky.
Delicious?
Nutritious?
Froggy?
Wait, what's over there?
We're crawling once again.
Oh, we can't see anything.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I actually can't see anything.
Is it just a hiding spot?
Wait.
Yes, it is.
Okay, just kidding.
Um.
I don't want to get attacked by the dogs.
Some rats to eat.
More food.
Come here, food.
Mike?
Dogs?
When did they come out?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's this part.
Oh.
That's a dog.
Wonder if...
Maybe the grenades would be good.
I only have five of them, though.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Don't notice me.
Please don't notice me.
I think I have to go over to that side.
I don't quite remember.
I think I can go in here.
Wait.
Dog?
Behind me?
Oh my god, there's a dog!
Oh my god!
Where was it that way?
Oh my gosh, I can't remember.
It's fine, we have a mat.
Can't remember.
Fork the dog.
Can I?
Oh no, not this one.
Well, we got some stuff here.
And another dog.
Oh wait, that's ammo.
Wait, this is...
How did you get over here?
Good.
Dogs can crawl.
Oh shoot.
I was wrong again?
Oh my god.
Now I'm swimming in open wounds.
Delicious.
Okay.
Over here.
It's gotta be.
No!
We're running.
Don't do it.
Don't do it, dog.
Oh wait.
I hear what?
I think.
Oh gosh.
We're running!
Queue the epic music.
Wait.
I haven't seen him in so long.
I love this part, though.
This part's so good.
He's waited for this moment.
That guy's pretty beat up, huh?
Okay, cool.
Finally.
I've been waiting for this.
Yeah!
Nobody interfere.
It's so good It's so good
This is where it ends
One Yeah
Oh my god Just stupid face here
Just barely Just barely Nearly a sk- Everyone's just like, if we had been able to interfere...
Don't die on me yet.
It's so good.
Oh!
The final Cobra unit member, let's call it.
I've been waiting for this.
My river is clean!
It'll be full of rats and fish!
Probably.
There should be no people in here!
There should be no people!
Oh my gosh.
Turn it up, baby.
Turn it up.
You're
one of the Cobras.
sad so sad a host of sorrows
and you are one of them
oh he looks so cool I am the sorrow like you I too am filled with sadness This world is one of sadness.
Battle brings death.
Death brings sorrow.
I haven't killed.
I've feasted upon frogs.
And bunnies.
Their voices.
Oh, you look so good.
They fall upon deaf ears.
But make no mistake.
The dead are not silent.
Now you will know the sorrow of those whose lives you have ended.
So cool.
Alright, let's see how many fish are in here.
Two?
There's so many fish!
Look how cool, look at the way he moves.
Hey, hey, I didn't kill that guy, he exploded.
It's not my fault.
It's not my fault he exploded.
Brace yourself.
Oh.
Ah!
How do I dodge it?
So stinking loud.
Get out of here, pain.
No!
Don't get at me!
Don't get me!
Don't grab me!
Maybe I have to dive to dodge it.
Yeah.
So cool.
Music is so good.
There we go.
Okay.
So it's the same as before.
Oh my gosh, I'm so bad at this.
It's hard, it's easier to tell in the original.
It's like a little swirly thing, but this time it's kind of difficult.
Maybe I'm stupid.
No, don't go after me.
It's way more transparent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, in this one it is.
Yeah.
I'll just keep the one side.
I mean...
Look at all these fish!
I should have killed some people, so we had some guys in my...
Not the bird!
I'm sorry, I got my stuff taken away!
I didn't get to feed you in the cage!
I'm kind of sad I don't have any guys now Whoa Oh you can't you can't That's kind of weird Oh my gosh Whoa what was that Who was that There was someone standing behind me
No it wasn't the fury behind me Uh oh I'm gonna get gots up So sorry, you guys.
So sorry, I'm really bad at dodging that for some reason.
There was somebody standing behind me.
Ugh.
It's all fish.
They didn't even include like any of the other animals that I've eaten.
They actually didn't.
It's only fish.
There's like no...
There's nothing else in here.
Oh, you can really see his body so clearly.
That's cool.
It is time for you to wake up.
Okay, before we do that.
Snake, you have to get up.
Snake!
Snake, what happened?
Snake, don't quit on me now.
Snake!
I went through this boss battle not too long ago and had the same issue as well.
They made his aim with the beam much more precise.
Ah, I see, I see.
Snake!
What happened to you?
Snake?
Snake!
Doesn't paramedic like cry?
Snake, are you okay?
Snake!
You know about the camera thing in this fight, right?
I don't know.
Actually, I don't think I remember.
What is the camera thing?
Snake, what happened?
Talk to me!
Snake!
I don't think I know.
I was like, if I do know, I don't remember.
Taking pictures?
around here shows developers wait really wait so hold on uh wait i don't think i put it in my backpack unless it's an item oh yes it's an item that would make more sense
uh so cool he looks so cool wait he actually looks so cool
hey there buddy Wait, let me see.
Can I see them?
Normally?
I don't want to die.
I'm just trying to keep that in mind.
I will!
Hold on!
Gosh.
Oh, I see!
I can see!
I see someone there!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Oh, I see!
I see someone else!
Uh...
No one here.
No one here?
You do not belong here.
I do, actually.
Ah!
In the corner!
The left bottom left corner!
You see him?
He's so smiley.
Oh my god!
Oh wait.
Uh...
I don't see anyone here.
It is time for you to...
Hold on, I'm having fun.
Ah!
The ghost photos are the OG version.
I don't...
I can't believe I never knew this.
Unless...
Maybe I was told, but I never did it myself.
Chica, thanks for the gifted.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Oh!
I'm sorry, I didn't see who raided me.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
D'Orgo, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
We're on the final Cobra fight.
Look at all them fish.
I love fish.
Getting all them amino acids, baby.
Hold on.
You're not my mom.
What is it?
Time for school?
I'm doing ghost photography.
My, my fan.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Ah, I see somebody in the middle, bottom, bottom, middle.
Okay, okay, okay, we do it, we do it.
Okay, how do I get...
Oh, there we go.
All right, so let's see.
We need this.
Wait.
Where is it?
Wait, is it, uh...
Wait, I can't remember how to...
I always forget how to do this.
Wait, huh?
Wait, I do have all my stuff.
Why?
Wait.
Why do I have all my stuff?
That's weird.
Oh, the dead body?
Come here.
Go to the body.
Aw, it shows her.
Oh, oops.
Wait, I forgot to...
Oh,
I forgot to...
Oh, I forgot to...
Oh, no, I pressed continue.
Oh my gosh, I'm so stupid.
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I'm so dumb.
I press...
I did it all wrong.
I always fluff this part.
I'm so sorry.
I get so excited.
I just forget everything.
Wait, what's that?
That's a skull.
I didn't do that.
I do like it.
Oh, please, please, please.
Oh, geez, okay.
Oops, all fish.
I like how he though it says back again.
It's cool.
It's fun.
I do this every time though.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
Stop taking my life wars.
You know, this is what I do to you guys every time you watch my streams and stuff.
Kind of like Sorrow, he's just a ghost dude.
Nice.
Way through water.
No, see when they're taking the life force.
I do that.
See, watch, watch.
Snake will glow.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna get God again.
Oh!
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Please no!
Oh, thank goodness.
It's so loud.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Thank you!
One is liquid, one is solid, you are a big boss.
Look at all them!
Fish!
Grandpa!
Look at he's like swimming after me.
Thank you.
Oh, I love this part.
I can't wait.
I was watching the remake trailer for Fatal Frame.
My one thing about it is I'm kind of worried that it's a little like okay So one thing I love about the older fatal brain games and what makes them work so well is they're extremely grainy And like it makes the ghost photography sometimes it looks like super legit,
you know Like the photos look super duper scary sometimes like they look almost real And...
And...
I just worry that...
Um...
Okay.
Alright.
We'll use this once we touch the bag.
Don't worry that it looks too clean, the remake.
But we'll see.
There we go.
Die!
Just kidding.
Oh no, he died!
You have to shoot me.
I can't.
Shoot me.
You want to finish your mission, don't you?
Then...
you'll have to shoot me.
The spirit of the warrior...
will always be with you.
Don't be sad.
We'll meet...
again someday.
No!
Come on, Snake!
Oh, it's so...
Whoa, whoa, the camera was so crazy looking.
Whoa, I wonder if that showed up well on YouTube.
Woof.
Too much water.
Four was okay.
The problem with Five is you ended up feeling more aroused than scared.
Five has one of my favorite visuals in the whole series though.
Where like Fuyuhi is like standing behind you.
It's towards the beginning of the game.
I love it.
And she's just kind of like her neck is all like...
Oh, here we go.
I don't know why it said mouse button.
It confused me for a second.
But Fatal Frame is so sexy and so scary at the same time.
See his victory against the sorrow.
The fear boner.
Don't say that.
So that really was.
Something on your mind, Snake?
Major, was there a man in the Cobra unit the sorrow yes I've heard of him he was an uncanny soldier who fought alongside the boss what kind of man was he the sorrow was a man with well special powers he had a SP which was a subject of extensive research in the Soviet Union at the time he was especially gifted as a medium a medium someone who can communicate with the spirit world you think he could talk to me in other words he could talk to ghosts they say he could find out what was going on in a battle by talking to dead soldiers what about him and the boss what was the sorrow between them I don't know this message the snake for me why don't we ask Sigind yo I finished checking up on this sorrow guy a while ago thought you guys already knew though knew what that he's dead he's been dead for two years now he died two years ago at Salino Yarsk you know those clips you were at mm-hmm and the boss is the one who did him in we saw his body yep two years ago the was sent by the CIA on a
secret mission to Salino Yarsk.
That's when she met the Sorrow, who'd gone back to the Soviet Union after the Cobras broke up at the end of the war.
Except this time they were enemies.
And then what?
The boss killed the Sorrow herself and accomplished her mission.
At least, that's what the records say.
So, he was never there in the first place.
He just couldn't let go of the boss.
You okay, Snake?
Yeah, I'm fine.
It looks like it's not time for me to die.
I sure hope not otherwise the whole mission is shot we're counting on you pal Roger that don't you care about my life Eva obviously he doesn't you didn't call I was worried are you alright yeah I took a pretty freaky detour what are you talking about yeah nothing forget it yeah I love that line good but how did you escape from the sewers I jumped into the river from all the way up there you're out of control yeah I got carried away by the current and almost drowned great that's perfect what do you mean that's perfect I mean if you ended up in the river then I know a good spot nearby let's meet up there okay where is it keep going upstream until you get to a waterfall okay a waterfall huh right behind that waterfall there's a cave we'll meet in there okay the cave behind the Waterfall upstream.
Got it.
See you there.
Unfortunately, they're already going to be on caution because I have the tracker in me.
But that's okay.
Wait, actually, which way do I go?
Okay, I'm faced downstream.
We need to go upstream.
Yeah, it's definitely worth it.
Do we want to kill now?
Just finish the...
Or just watch the fantastic reality mod.
Last time I was teared up a little bit watching you perform.
Joshua, thank you!
Thank you.
I could kill.
I don't care.
What the heck are those?
Those things right there.
Um, wait, hold on.
I'm all lost.
I'm all turned around.
Okay, we go this way.
Why did I go this way?
I don't think so.
Why am I so lost?
Those are the mangoes?
Where do I go up?
I'm so lost.
Where do I go?
I can't, I don't recognize anything.
Go, go, go.
Eh?
Wait.
Hello, get it done.
There we go.
Okay, sorry.
Sorry about that.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I've been a little out of it today.
I'll be honest.
Oh.
You ever like feel like, okay, like you are don't belong in your own skin.
That's how I've been feeling today.
I don't ever feel like that.
It's a very bizarre feeling.
Like, I just wanted to, like, you know, tear off my skin today.
I don't really know how else to describe it.
way right yes I mean like it's not so much a problem for me I just have the ectoplasm you know but I think I just didn't sleep well oh my gosh you're on high alert you see that guy over there they're gonna I could just wait I can't Go into the waterfall if it's in alert mode,
I think.
So I'm going to have to be careful.
We might need to kill.
Did you possess the wrong person?
Oh, maybe.
Right.
Maybe, maybe.
Can you remove the tracker?
You can.
But there is a funny cutscene that I want to get.
It's a funny cutscene.
it's really worth it I promise whoa whoa I didn't know this was here oh wow okay it's like my favorite track in the whole game because it reminds me of him I forgot that guy was up there but I'm too good maybe a little bit actually we'll have our gun out just so we can hold people up maybe if I can I'm not stupid nothing no one nowhere nothing no one nothing yeah you're seeing things exactly oh shoot how do I get past that guy I guess I could just maybe if I hug the wall oh shit we're going we're running the waterfalls are at the Can we go in?
Oh, that is...
Ah!
Shoot!
Why am I on the ground?
Dive!
Easy.
Oh, God is it here.
Don't worry about it.
Eva will patch us all up.
Freaking batch.
Ah!
Raw, man.
And that thing she's been using.
Oh boy, guys.
Nice
to meet you, Snake.
I'm Tatiana.
Thanks.
Smile.
Here's your equipment.
Yippee!
We're free.
You could use a towel.
So could you.
Yeah, I could use a lot of help, actually.
Ah, nice.
He's chowing down.
Booty.
Oh!
Want some?
No, thanks.
Toes?
Don't like snakes?
Not for dinner.
Hmm.
Didn't you have to eat them at the KGB?
In my training, we always have the good stuff.
French, Italian.
That kind of thing.
A regular Matahari.
The least you could do is call me Cynthia.
Cynthia Harrow.
Tell me something.
How does it feel to spy on your own country?
I can't say it feels good, but it's my job.
Can't even eat a snake during a mission, huh?
There's fish.
I wouldn't mind eating you.
When this mission's over, you'll have to treat me to a nice dinner.
What do you want to eat?
Sushi!
Yami!
It's Japanese.
I hear it's all the rage right now.
Supposedly it's made from raw fish.
Raw fish.
Women are confusing.
Just a place for my survival techniques.
She won't eat raw fish here, but she'll eat raw fish at the sushi restaurant.
Women are strange.
Snake.
Thank you, Snake.
your eyes from now on I'm searching and I'll melt into you
what a fear in my heart but you're so supreme that still hurts that's fresh Eva my
man is not reciprocating at all are
you all right it's not like I can't see I've got one good eye and can still fire a gun.
Good.
Yeah, good.
Snake.
Oh, here we go.
Come here for a minute.
This is what we left the tracker in for, everybody.
What is the whole thing?
There's something in here.
It's so hard.
Oh.
When did it get like that?
Hold still.
Let me do it.
You know, I've been trained to do this kind of thing myself just relax and let me handle it the cheering gets me every time it is yeah but it gets the job done really here lift up your hips like this yeah pretty good at that yeah everybody tells me that hold steady I'm not done yet there a transmitter Is that how they do it in the KGB?
Sometimes.
Would you rather I did it American style?
But how do you know there was a transmitter lodge there?
That's some female intuition you've got.
Them, like, spinning around holding hands is so cute.
Yeah, I wonder what American style is.
Yay!
We got our clothes back on!
Eva, didn't you steal some explosives out of the fortress?
C3, a highly potent explosive from the west.
Her and the Tatiana outfit is too cute.
It can be molded into any shape like clay.
With just this much, you could blow up the Shagohad and the lab along with it.
Is that right?
Are you sure about that?
Yeah, but there's a trick to using it.
Tell me about it.
She's molding it.
She's so cute.
She's so stinking cute.
Yeah.
Eva.
I mean, Tatiana.
The Shagohod's booster unit uses liquid fuel.
The fuel tanks are in the main wing of the weapons lab in the hangar housing the Shagohod itself.
So I should blow up the tanks.
That's the basic idea.
It should be enough to blow up the entire hangar.
four fuel tanks in order to destroy the hangar you'll have to set explosives on each of those tanks all four of them it should be no sweat for you besides the scientists had the day off today yippee so the hangar is completely deserted not quite they've still got guards posted there so what do i do after i set the c3 the bombs run off a timer oh once the timer has been set this part you guys when the timer reaches zero the bombs will all go off at once how long do i have 20 minutes once the phase 2 trials are finished I wouldn't be surprised if they kill all the scientists to prevent them from talking so you've got to act fast I'll take care of it you got this thank you this part is always tough mmm Eva did you get the data on the shag on from Sokolov yeah that's the mission I was given by Khrushchev mm-hmm America doesn't have any use for it does it she's so pretty I haven't forgotten my other mission either got She's so pretty.
Helping you out.
Follow this cave and go up the ladder at the end.
She's such a tease.
She's just southwest of the weapons lab.
I gotta put on my new outfit.
Do you remember when you went to rescue Sokolov?
Yep.
Remember there was a locked door when you entered the main wing from the second floor of the east wing?
Yep, well, I don't remember it was lost.
That's the entrance to the Shagohod's hangar.
Use this key to open that door.
Thank you.
The door, right when I enter the main wing?
Got it.
What about you?
I'll get things ready for our escape.
Wait, he says things are so good.
There's a rail bridge to the north.
Got it.
I'm gonna set a bomb there, so I'm taking half of the C3 with me.
No, I think I could use all of it, honestly.
Try not to be in the neighborhood when it happens.
out for us a lot he suspects you're not who you say you are don't worry the Colonel still trusts me and I have my ways got it there's not a man alive who can resist my charms besides you of course I'm just warning you Eva that's all I know okay let's go would you guys be able to resist you seem like you were born on one of those Aw.
If I didn't ride every day, I couldn't go on living.
When I'm riding, the wind hits me so hard that it hurts.
That pain keeps my mind off the pain of having to be someone else.
It's not easy always fooling myself like this.
No.
It's only when I'm on the bike that I'm free to be the real me.
I only get off my bike when I fall in love.
or fall dead what's your name Tatiana no your real name what's wrong with Tanya huh okay Tanya don't let anyone see you oh this it's a button camera what did you do that for insurance to make sure you don't double-cross me
own her bike when she falls alive falls dead
she's taking photos of her oshi
nice oh more ammo wait how much ammo do i have actually oh i think about it we can take out this as much as it hurts me um
Oh, what else do I have?
Smokernan?
Or snakes?
You know what?
I don't want to eat that.
I think our...
Yeah, we're all full now.
Um...
We have 41!
Okay.
Nice.
Welcome to bamboo ship.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Unfortunately, our disguise does not work.
anymore our uh rykov disguise diptych diptych diptych diptych bandage oh we're full no please i need it damn thank you so much for the 20 give them thank you thank you should i bring the hats okay baby Give the parrot back to the forest.
Do I even still have him?
Oh, wait.
Under food.
They got rid of my parrot.
They took out everything.
Where are my naked snake checkies?
Ribbit.
No, we're full.
No.
Please, I'm gonna run out.
The croc disguise?
Oh, yeah, so true.
Where is it?
Oh.
We're gonna have to not wear it for a bit, though, Sasad.
Because we need
We need to dress up like a proper man.
Actually, go back to the parrot if you head outside the water while hanging out of a tree.
No way?
Is he still there?
But he's dead.
We know.
We saw him in the river.
Saying grandpa.
He's dead.
And he ain't coming back.
Same with the Tsuchinoko.
Oh, this is the other Tsuchinoko area.
The way he so casually walks back.
wait thermals oh I didn't I didn't equip the thermals so sorry everybody for your eyes that's a frog is that him no those are plants what is that is that a person or to
the left what
is that is that him in the tree I can't tell what
Hold on.
Let me also get my binoculars.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, there he is!
This is him!
I see his back.
Oh, it's him!
Wait, what was...
That?
What the hell?
Oh, it's just a crow.
I was like, what is that thing?
It's, oh my god.
It's a raven, yeah.
Are there guys still here?
Oh, no.
Oh!
I think he took off.
He took off.
I saw his little feathers.
All right, all right.
Eva took him out?
Where's the Tutsi Naka?
I don't think I ever, I don't know if I've ever explored this area.
Yeah.
Wait.
Okay, that's just a place to crawl.
Oh, birds.
Little birds.
Okay, I know where we are.
Do you ever get him before the torture scene?
No.
In fact, oh, don't bite me, please.
I don't think I have ever gotten one.
Wait, can I eat this guy?
Come here.
Wait, come here.
What are you?
I hope you weren't poisonous.
We're fine.
Then it's not here?
Aw, man.
Dang.
Oh, well.
Well, we got to see the bird.
That was cute.
Alright.
Back to Croc.
Yeah, all muddy.
Authentic crocodile.
Look at his shadow.
Look at the shadow on the wall!
Where is that?
Oh, sneaky.
Sneaky duck.
But...
Shadow tan.
I still have not found.
Thank you so much for the pit, they get that well.
Thank you!
Ah, I found them!
Yeah, we got them both this time.
Photo mode.
shadow puppets?
Okay.
Watching my Oshi play MGS3 while playing Death Stranding, enjoying Popeyes!
Peak day indeed.
Sounds so nice.
Getting close to a year now.
Sura, thank you!
Alrighty.
Where do I get the uniform?
Don't reach out.
I sure hope nobody blocks our escape.
You know, we came out of here.
I sure hope nobody seals it shut.
Nobody notice.
He's huge.
Rikov lockers have uniform.
Okay.
Dang, I have to go...
Well, I guess I have to go through there anyway, I don't know.
Don't stand up, Snake!
Okay, I know there's dogs around here now.
Okay, alright.
We can go through that door.
And go back inside.
Not if you use a cardboard box to fast travel.
Which car...
Which...
what do I jump into to fast travel
oh why are there so many of you hello
why back of a truck to the north I don't know which direction I'm even facing right now oh I know where it is okay I do know I do know it's like past there through oh Gakko I see him.
I'm getting deja vu.
Me too.
I'm getting a what's wrong?
Loop deja vu right now.
There's so many guys!
Oh, jeez.
Okay.
I just gotta try.
It might be easier if he's like further away, you know.
Oh.
Oh, where are you going?
You're not going to say what's wrong?
What's wrong?
There we go.
Save the line, Bart!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh no.
Wait.
Oh shoot.
Oh no, it's happening again.
It's not happening again.
Why is my aim so bad?
Okay.
It's not happening again.
We've managed to avoid looping.
Okay.
That guy and the dog is asleep.
I see the truck.
Cardboard box B.
To Weapons Lab Hangar.
But they still won't have the uniform.
Oh, wait.
The weapons...
Beast wing.
What is that?
Which...
What?
Where is this?
I guess you gotta go through the long way for Camel.
I think so.
The hangar drop-off point is close to the lockers.
Is it?
Oh, yeah.
Because it's right next.
two hopefully you know what let's try let's try for it i think there was one more guy i'm gonna i'm scared i'm up upping my camo i'm upping my camo
i was just even more impressive
i'm 60 now there's a guy over there
I hear him walking.
I see a dog.
Oh, I see Kero-tan.
One thing we don't want is this guy to turn around.
If he does...
Owarida.
Owarida!
Wait.
Okay, now...
We become...
I don't think I equipped it.
Okay, hi, oh boy.
Cardboard box, boy.
Let's go.
Suit is good, but Croc hat makes it perfect.
Hey!
Oh, I took off the hat.
Aw.
Are
you...
Waddy duck head.
We're right by the stairs, so we might be okay i see you've managed to sneak into the hangar somehow yeah the shagahods in here the completed phase two shagahod represents a grave threat to the west we can't allow it to be mass produced you've got to destroy it okay eva's got the data on the shagahod do you think that's safe well i wouldn't exactly say it's safe but khrushchev is a shrewd leader i can't imagine he'd use it for anything other than deterrence deterrence vulgin however is a different story he's planning to use the shagahod to turn the cold war into a blazing hot one we can't let him have it agreed that leaves just one more mission for you to carry out battle suit looks so cool exactly for now just focus on destroying the shagahod yes sir i'll let sigint fill you in on how to destroy it yo like eva was saying if you're looking to blow the whole place sky high the best way is to take out those liquid fuel tanks with the c3 you know there's four tanks in there right you have
to put c3 on all four of them yeah to plan a c3 charge all you gotta do is equip the c3 and well they like if i crouch walk just like tnt but uh make sure you don't plant it in the wrong place you barely got enough c3 as it is right okay good point i'll make sure not to plant anywhere else could man and be careful liquid fuel has a nasty habit of going off at the slightest shock so don't go using any heavy firepower near the tanks unless aiming to get yourself barbecued.
Barbecue!
I'll keep that in mind.
The C3 charges all have to go off at once if you want to bring down the hangar in one fell swoop.
So if I were you, I'd wait until after you plant the last charge to start the timer mechanism.
All right.
I'll make sure I finish planting all four charges before I start the timer.
Once the timer's set, you've got 20 minutes until it explodes, right?
Sweet the skies in one of the lockers?
I think that's about all I've got.
The rest is up to you.
Good luck, pal.
Thank you.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, so we're next to the stairs, but if I remember correctly, there's a guy like right there.
So we gotta be mighty careful.
I'm trying to decide what I want to do.
This is...
This could be worse, but it's...
Not great.
Box.
We'll keep the box.
But if they see me walking in it, there's no point.
You know what?
Let's just go for it and see what happens.
Oh, wait.
Let me out.
Thank you.
Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
If I remember quickly, the guy is like facing the other way anyway, so it's fine.
Sneakings!
Looks so good.
My only thing about this one is I don't like the orange on it, but it just, it does look really good.
Now, where is the janitor's outfit, the little guy?
Wow, the detail on it's kind of crazy, actually.
But what do them belts do, mister?
Uh, locker closest to the window.
Okay, thank you.
I ride them.
Hopefully, we don't get caught.
I'm scared of someone coming around the corner.
Other side, second from the left?
What?
The window?
Or...
Ah!
Nah, there we go.
There we go, there we go.
Do you think they'll like my crock suit?
I think I called it a janitor.
He's maintenance.
Do you think they'll like the crock hat?
Will they be suspicious with it?
Oh, that's right.
I can't use this when...
Um, one thing is, uh...
Where?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, let's get rid of...
Milksnake.
Alright, we got our C3.
Look at that booty!
This is so messed up.
Is it the crock hat?
Is
it the crock hat?
Is it that?
No.
They wouldn't.
They love it.
I might just die and redo this part.
Let's see.
Hold on.
No silly lad, clearly.
Gosh.
Oh wait.
What if we still are able to do this?
We're fine.
This is one of them, right?
Is it?
Wait, is it this one?
No.
Am I crazy?
I know that one's down.
Oh, it's the little... Okay, it's the tank looking thing.
Wait, how do I place this?
What am I doing wrong?
None up there.
Oh, here we go.
Wait, how do I place it?
How do I...
How do I place this?
No.
Don't worry about me.
RT, that's what I'm putting.
That's what I'm doing.
Ah!
It's because I was crouched.
Okay.
Good to know.
Snake?
Eba.
I finished planting the bomb on the rail bridge.
Only placing caution or lower.
Ah, that's why.
Okay.
That should at least buy us some time.
I've also set up the escape route.
How are things going on your end?
I just finished planting the second child.
Silly is allowed!
Give me a little more time.
Okay.
They're busy looking for a guy and a croc at it.
They don't know.
Do they?
Uh-oh.
Don't catch me.
These dang... These guys are such snitches.
Oh my god, he's right there.
I can't leave.
Wait, is he?
Yeah, he's right there.
Okay.
We'll wait for him to go.
Oh my gosh, please leave.
I see his head.
Wait, did he just leave?
Was that him running away?
Oh, nice.
Please don't see me.
I am just a measly guy.
Uh-oh, wait.
Can't do it with this guy here.
Can you see?
How does she do it?
Wait, but I don't want the frog mask for the next cutscene because I want to see a little smile.
How does she get away with it?
How does she do it?
Wow.
Easy game.
I can't believe he undoes her heart.
It's kind of messed up.
Got you this time.
Yeah!
Nice.
No one sees this.
Major, I finished planting the C3.
I'm on my way out now.
Is Eva taking care of the escape room?
No, I kind of wish I had the frog mask on.
She can handle it.
Alright then, we'll hurry up and get out of there.
Now I kind of wish I had it on.
It's time!
Uh-oh.
She looks so peaceful.
Oh, I can't with this guy.
Why'd you come back?
Iconic moment.
Uh-oh.
Yes, please.
Yeah, save, please.
Ah, 13.
15 minutes, baby.
And then the clock just keeps on ticking down.
This woman was found snooping around my underground vault.
When she was captured, look what we found on her.
What?
The Philosopher's Legacy.
Everyone in this room is curious about that.
This microfilm contains only information regarding the legacy.
You might say that this film itself is the philosopher's legacy.
It was the smell that gave her away.
No, not the perfume.
Ah, gasoline, baby.
It was gasoline.
Ah, yeah, I called it.
Motorcycle gasoline.
Just kidding.
She reeked of it.
Hi, Sorrow.
To think that lovely...
Tatyana was a spy.
Oh, lovely Tatyana.
We found this radio along with her too.
Yeah, that's really obvious looking.
That thing is huge.
Such a fine woman she was.
It almost pains me to have to kill her.
Where did she keep that?
right obedient one she was my precious little pet such a weirdo isn't that right precious little pet what was that do you have something to say to me oh kiss of death go to hell you
dirty whore I've had enough kisses from you.
I love that line so much you guys don't even understand.
Just like the KGB to send something so beautiful, yet so deadly.
I've had enough kisses from you.
Very well.
I'll explain it before I kill you.
Oh yeah.
During the last great war.
The most powerful men in America, China, and the Soviet Union had a secret pact.
I've had enough kisses from you.
The pact was a blueprint for defeating the Axis powers and creating a new world order.
Yeah, explain the whole thing, please.
The three countries pooled their resources to conduct the most covert types of operations and research.
The atomic bomb, rocket technology, the Cobra unit.
I'm gonna be eating a coffee after this.
And they amassed an enormous sum of money to fund these projects, enough to fight the war five times over.
That wealth is the philosopher's legacy.
Woo!
After the war was won, the three countries were to divide the philosopher's legacy amongst themselves.
This explains why the United States and the Soviet Union were able to steal away the best scientific minds in Germany as soon as the war ended.
But our great motherland has far surpassed its pathetic rivals.
We possess enormous wealth, the most advanced technology, and overwhelming power, assets fitting of our great country.
They could have just printed them.
My father was one of the men in charge of managing the philosopher's legacy.
In the confusion that ensued after the war ended, he devised a series of ingenious plots to ensure that the Soviet Union will have total...
control over the legacy i have an alt twitter account was divided up that's just for like me looking at metal gear stuff and retweeting metal gear stuff it's mostly yowie but my twitter banner banner is i've had enough is that screenshot it's that line i've had enough kisses from you i love that line so much after my father's death i learned of this secret and obtained the microfilm
of Brezhnev and his allies I built this fortress of Grosnygrad and Granin's research facility but that worthless fool Granin failed to produce results I like retweet only I only retweet things that I want to see and then the shaggle sometimes devil may cry and also me gongaga that's like my position in grew made it too troublesome to attack Sokolov's facility directly but the network established by the secret pact still existed I used it to contact the boss and suggested that she defect the boss was conniving enough to see things my way I love their family photo world was once one but the conflict between the philosophers you think the end is awake here we will use the legacy to heal that rift and make the world whole again he looks mighty sleepy to do this we need strength an unstoppable trump card with enough power to bring order to the world how do you make that trump card was to be the shagohad and the Cobra I just made it oh look at them they're so cute
anyway I have lost the Cobras but I still have the Shagohad and the legacy well there is nothing America can do to stop us Boss, take this someplace safe.
Oh, yeah, he still trusts her.
Take good care of it.
You wouldn't have come waltzing back in here unless he had a reason.
The C3's been stolen.
No, I've been skipping back in here.
I've been hopping around in here.
I was a frog.
I'll go see if there are any surprises waiting for us.
I'll dispose of her as well.
Yes.
Boss is such a girl's girl.
Ah, I love them.
So cool i know fight like a warrior vulgan but of course how much time we got left
i'm obsessed with whoever did his mocap his facial mocap let me face him oh geez i've been waiting for this moment time to get even you've said that like five times now
oh yeah
No more judo and no more field strips It's not judo.
It's CQC Silly No more gun flips no more gun twirling Nah, I don't I never want him to stop
Enough of this
Uh-oh The gloves are off baby He's mine You will stand right there and watch.
Got it?
Please, Colonel, let me...
Meanwhile,
the timer...
I know!
I have to pee so bad, actually.
So, before the fight, I will pee.
How much time we got left?
Oh, seven.
minutes okay thank you go piss girl sorry for the delay I will let's get started shall we shall we our own little arena
I think those pants are too tight for Make it a good one.
It's just you and me now.
So cool!
And I'm going to enjoy this.
I'm sure you will.
Oh my god.
You're mine, son of the boss.
Okay, and then I pause.
Pause, pause.
Then we pause and I go pee.
And then we get everything all situated here.
And...
Five minutes, baby.
Pause?
No!
I wonder what she's up to.
I kind of want to go pet her and kiss her head.
If I take a little bit longer, I'm petting her and I'm kissing her head.
Oh, here, you guys can look at his butt in this because...
I just heard something behind me.
I hope it's not a ghost because I should be the only one haunting this place.
My real concern is I hope it wasn't a bug that fell from the ceiling.
The tree frog and glow cabs.
Oh, I forgot to grab the glow cabs when we were in the sewers.
I have no food or anything on me.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I might be in trouble.
Yeah, we're fine.
Okay, anyway, I'll be right back.
My kittens are cute.
Yeah.
All right.
All right, baby.
Let's put on this.
It's like the perfect time.
Handle.
Oh, come on.
Wait, can I not?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, he's winking at me.
Do you wash your hands?
I always do.
Okay.
Croc time, of course.
Wait, I can't put on the mask.
Oh, interesting.
I guess because of the headdress.
Major.
Is that you?
We'll put it on eventually.
I like when he gets a little flurry.
lestered over seeing it.
I can never remember how to do this fight.
I literally did it not even that long ago.
I can't remember.
That's okay though.
We'll figure it out.
What do I have?
I guess we'll do non-lethal as I've been.
CQC.
Um.
I don't have any glow caps, so don't even mention it.
Stop talking about it.
As you can see.
We have some rations, though.
What's my food like, anyway?
My stamina is...
It's okay.
Use my judo.
Toss out the rotten food.
Like, to him?
He won't care.
I wonder if I throw out the tree frog.
But it's not alive, so I don't think he'll care.
Yeah, they're rotten.
Someone said chaff grenades.
I'll try.
We don't need the C3 anymore.
Bullets are no good because he stops them.
I think I just gotta dodge everything.
I don't have to...
Okay, I remember it.
It's coming back to me.
I hit him.
And then I can stun him.
Not gonna lie, Mint.
This game's a weird one.
weird.
What?
Yeah, the roll helps.
Yes.
Okay, let's get into it, baby.
Hello!
Whoa.
Why am I so slow all of a sudden?
Okay, come here.
Oh, shoot!
Wait!
Where's my gun?
Oh my gosh, I didn't have it.
Oh.
Nice.
Here it come.
What is coming?
Ouch!
Oh, out.
Okay, sorry.
Okay.
Putcher.
and just run.
Oh, I can only get, like, one hit in, okay.
Oh, let's do this real quick.
I got a gunshot wound.
I'm bleeding.
Oh, disinfected.
The way he just, like, drops to the ground is too good.
Okay, we got to be aggressive because...
Because we don't have much time left!
Thank you, Asula!
Ouch!
Ouch, Ouch, out, out, out.
Get up, please.
Down, down, just run!
Just run!
Come on!
Oh!
Phase 2 already?
Okay.
Shoot him!
Do you hear me?
I said shoot him!
Sorry, Colonel.
I'm afraid I can't do that.
What do you mean you can't?
I made a promise to the boss.
Silence!
I am your commander.
officer
he's so insane he's so insane I missed the part where that's my problem are you questioning my authority
why does it look like that
fight like a man Vulcan Vulcan emergency Explosives have been detected.
Uh-oh.
Hold not EOD personnel must evacuate immediately.
Ocelot, find those bombs!
I like how he's still pointing at him.
Repeat.
Explosives have been detected.
Hold not EOD personnel must evacuate immediately.
Moving!
Huh.
Ready for some more, Snake?
sir wait one second one second one second one second oh my gosh okay uh get it out uh disinfected uh wait stop the bleeding bandage okay our ears fine right oh oops it's fine oh i can't go up just kidding i'm i'm just zooming in on his crotch.
I'm not trying to.
Here's where... Okay, we're in phase two.
I'm gonna eat a ration.
Because we're gonna start getting hungry.
Sick.
But...
Do I change?
Oh, well, no, we can change during the next bit.
We should be able to.
I think.
I think we should be able to.
Sick!
Accidentally... I was trying to zoom up!
I was!
Yeah, I want to change back for cutscenes.
But I think the battle suit is good for this because it helps us take less damage.
Okay, anyway.
Maybe right before I beat him up!
We don't have a lot of time!
Oh, oops, I did not.
Oh, well, this works actually.
Uh, I'm bleeding, I'm bleeding, I'm bleeding.
Uh, bandage.
And disinfect.
There we go.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
There we go.
Okay, somehow I got him.
Oh my gosh, I only have two minutes left.
Come on.
Go again.
The CQC is so easy in this game, it's awesome.
Yeah.
Is this where I get on the ground?
Oh no, this is where I run!
This is where he does the shoot across the field.
Oh my gosh.
It's so funny.
Oh no, wait, now he's...
Ow!
Oh god, he isn't...
well I avoided that somehow
just a few more it might be giddy giddy it might be giddy
one man we're
fine maybe oh my god oh my god please ouch ouch ouch ouch oh god no
Please let me take him down!
Oh my gosh!
Yes!
Yeah!
Wait, oh, uh, shoot, wait.
What do I do here?
Uh, shoot, what do I do?
Uh, is it, is it?
Wait, is it just...
I can't remember.
I can't remember if there's something special I have to do.
Or if it's just gonna fade the bell out.
He's black.
He's done.
Okay, we're done.
Oh yeah, the timer's gone.
Yippee!
Ah, okay.
Ah, I can't remember.
I was like, wait, is there something special I need to do here?
Yeah!
We got?
Ah!
First try, baby!
Woo!
That was so clutch.
Holy moly.
I almost didn't make it.
There's like 18 seconds left or something.
Crazy.
Holy...
Oh, come on.
It was just...
Trank.
Get out of there.
Uh-oh.
I hope Johnny makes it out.
I have to crocodile walk out of there.
See you later, alligator.
Let's get out of here quick!
Real?
Good!
So frantic about it too.
I know that croc anywhere.
Uh-oh.
Should have got more water while I was out, sorry.
I'll get some before the next fight the next boss fight I mean we're close you guys the boss let me go the boss but why I'll tell you later right now we've got to get to the lake and escape we can't leave yet I've still got one last job to do the boss is already at the lake huh she's at the lake she's waiting for you waiting for me he's chopping down on her I was hoping I wouldn't have to tell you I don't want you to fight her God he she loves her croc but I I've come to realize that there's a special relationship between you two something I can't understand something that goes beyond a man and a woman I envy you I love you Krak I guess I just can't understand it she asked me to tell you something I've never seen someone with such clear eyes well
there I said it what was it Ready to go?
Here she comes!
Screaming at us!
Snake!
It's not over yet!
Not yet, Snake!
There is no escape!
We failed Not good Not good Alright baby
Okay I'm gonna start killing people Oh wait Let me equip my stuff It's time to start killing I've wasted I've been good enough Okay everybody Wait what should we do which one should we use the AK Jack is back which one which one Scorpion maybe the AK the pacifist run you're right you're right maybe
let's Whatever.
We can get the people.
Woohoo!
I love that this is all in the engine.
I mean, the other thing's in the engine, but it's so good.
Oh, oh, oh.
My aim?
Wait, it's like one hit.
Wait, that's crazy.
Oh, my aim?
Come
on.
You drive better.
Not me.
uh who else am i getting
who's here oh oops oops oops oops just keep going just drive we're fine oops
i'm reloading oops oops
where's your aim don't worry about it okay um
oh my gosh wait have i been using my suppressors?
No.
Crank the shaggle hut?
Yeah.
Put the shaggle hut to sleep!
Oh, uh...
Sam, we made it out.
No worries.
What?
We're almost there.
Get out of the way!
Just drive!
Oh, PG can't put a dent in that armor.
Just drive.
Let's head for the rail bridge.
Yeah, just drive.
I think you can leave.
If he's stuck right now, you could just go.
Then blow him up long with it.
Good plan.
The bridge is on the other side of the runway.
We'll have to cut through the middle of the base.
You ready?
Step on it.
If he catches up to us, we're done for.
Oh!
Ah!
How could you miss?
Okay, here we go.
That's embarrassing.
Oh, he's getting put on the big gear.
Morning, Sean.
It's his heart.
He doesn't actually want to miss.
He knows this.
He doesn't actually want it to hit.
He wants to miss.
Grab him by the hair.
Grab him by the snout.
Woo!
We forgot to twirl.
Okay, watch where we're driving.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, cool.
Oh my god, she's just blacking them.
Wow.
So sexy.
Oh.
Don't worry, I won't kill you!
Don't worry!
Don't let him get away, he says.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm aiming.
Oh, we just drove fast, everybody.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, hold on, one second, one second.
Oh, one second, one second.
Oh, I got him.
I got him.
Okay.
Oh, I got him.
Nice.
Helicopter.
Oh, no, that's not a helicopter.
That's a man.
Oh, my aim.
Oh, my gosh!
Holy cow!
Uh, can I get you?
There we go.
Who else is aiming?
Oh, thank you.
God, a stinking RPG on me!
You're
gone.
You were there and...
Oh, you're gone?
Okay, wait, we're fine.
The cross suit is very sick, everybody, okay?
Like, don't worry even a little bit about it.
I got one.
I got two.
Reloading.
Don't come at me.
Got three.
Got four.
Got five.
Uh, six.
Uh, anyone with an RPG?
I don't know.
Oh, thank you.
You can't just say above, Eva.
Where are we driving in circles?
We were already here, no.
Like, we can leave.
Just escape.
There you go.
I don't even see people.
I'm blind.
I didn't get to see people.
a single one.
My eye is out.
Please, understand.
Move the aim.
Oh, stun grenades?
Yeah.
That probably would have been good, huh?
We're fine.
Okay, but then...
We'll see how fine we are,
Damn it!
Why are you killing them?
Just keep...
It's not their fault.
You're so slow.
Why did the helicopter decide to do that?
Like, why was the helicopter like, Oh yeah, I'll try and pick you up, buddy.
in front of them.
Here he comes!
I hope this is three miles of highway.
Alright, now I need the RPG, huh?
Now I need it, huh?
Wait, I have one, right?
Yeah.
I'll get rid of my fork.
You
guys are tough You guys are so fast Oh, I got you Okay, nice I got you Oh, I didn't mean
to Lucky Oh, not lucky Ouch, I'll challenge Ouch, I'll challenge Oh, my God Right in between them There we go Take out the driver You take out everybody What the?
That?
Okay I was gonna say that.
That hit, that hit.
Am I gonna be okay?
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
How does Eva have so much more health than me?
Might want to throw the battle suit on.
We'll do it for the fight, we will.
No one shoots the babe, so true.
I thought the crock suit was so thick.
I've
got a surprise for you.
You won't be getting away this time.
Uh-oh.
Oh, so hard.
Yippee!
Son of a bitch!
This face.
We just have a great skincare routine to recover.
from that.
Look
at the croc hat, it's just...
Okay, um...
What if I RPG...
And miss.
Okay.
Can I get it again?
And we
should...
What am I supposed to do about missiles?
Oh, my gosh!
I'm just a crocodile!
I'm just a poor croc!
Oh, that one.
It's not good.
Trank them.
All right, we're gonna get our, uh, what's it called out?
Here comes the missiles.
Dorifto!
Oh, the croctail.
The croctail almost hitting the ground.
It's cracking me up.
We've only got one chance.
We'll lure him over towards the other side.
What'd you say?
When the Shagohara is on the bridge, shoot the explosives.
The bomb is planted on the strut of the bridge.
Okay.
I'll shoot it.
I'll shoot it real good.
I won't miss.
Keep going!
Mint perfect shot?
Always, always, always.
Let's go.
I don't know why she keeps stopping, you know.
Why do you keep stopping the car?
It's my question.
Like, why are you doing
that?
It's not a car.
You're not a genius.
You know exactly what I'm talking about.
She has motion sync.
She has to do it.
Okay, one second, Eva, I gotta equip it in my backpack!
Where do I...
Wait, I already... I'm holding it.
Wait, I'm holding it.
Just kidding.
Oh, RB.
Wait, where is it?
Oh.
Okay, uh...
Down?
Why'd you tell me to shoot?
She's trolling or something.
Like, what the hell?
Oh my god!
No!
Now you're nothing.
How did it get better from that?
After like, wait.
We did it!
Sling's on like a little roach.
It's over.
Where'd my hat go?
Wait a second!
finished yet meet
the fighting to me that's yeah you got it i was getting tired of running away anyway eva let's do it here
goes all
right wait wait wait wait wait wait please i gotta go get some water
mint lucky kiss win hey if you mod me into the game as eva you could You could have...
You could have the experience.
What
was I gonna say?
Oh, water.
I'm gonna go get water, I'm so sorry.
My hero is a little...
Then we will do this fight, and then we have just a little bit more, and then we have one more fight, and then we're done!
Okay.
Be our way.
Okay, I'm back.
My roommate made fun of me.
because I didn't think anybody was home.
And so when I was getting water, I was like, booboo booboo booboo booboo booboo booboo booboo booboo booboo booboo.
They were like, um, hello?
Uh, okay.
All right.
Um, Snake is a little worse for wear in terms of health so we will put on the battle dress um so that we can have and let's eat some food oh wait our salmon is all the way so cool okay should be used to it by now that's i i honestly feel so too and the croc cap yeah we gotta put that on hokie dokey or we do keratan mask
Nice!
Hey!
Okay.
So thinking loud, oh my gosh.
Um, hello?
Hello?
Why did we stop?
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, I forgot how to do these.
Um, I think I shoot them!
Ouch!
Okay, I think those I need to AK, right?
I can't move.
Um, hello?
Shagohan?
Where do I...
Where do I fight him up?
Hank and the Rockets, huh?
Uh, yeah, that's what I do be doing.
Back of the head.
Right there.
Yes.
Okay.
You're wearing him down.
I am.
I'm...
I, too, am worn down.
But I need you to get to the back.
Eva!
Eva, there we go, there we go.
There we go.
Yes.
Oh, oops.
He turned.
Eva, please keep driving.
Eva, please.
Oh, uh...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Please!
Ah!
That was too late.
It's okay, our health is actually not so bad, surprisingly.
Please, please.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Why is it not?
Why is it...
Why is he tanking it?
I mean, I know he's a tank, but why is he tanking it?
Going!
Keep going, Iba!
Keep going.
Oh
my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so bad at these.
I'm like stupid bad at these.
Nice.
A trench!
Alright, come on, come on.
Why is this happening?
So funny.
Oh gosh, okay.
I hate the missiles, please.
I hate the missiles.
What?
Good hit, thank you.
Okay.
Shotgun?
Really?
Wait until they line up.
Oh!
Ah!
I got it!
Yes!
Let's go!
Let's go, let's go!
We're gaming!
Oh, I was.
I was gaming.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Wait, where'd you go?
Where'd you go?
There we go.
Oops, dang it.
Oh, ah!
I still hit!
Somehow.
Someway.
Oh my gosh, please!
Whop!
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Oh,
my gosh.
More of them, more of them.
It's just one, right?
Is that the last one?
Why is this happening?
Oops.
Ah, so close.
I don't want to do phase two, you guys.
I don't want to do phase two.
That trance.
And...
Yippee!
I don't want to do phase two!
Ugh.
Did we beat him?
No.
I hate phase two.
Game is so good.
Oh,
he's so freaky.
The way it's going into his arm!
Ew!
Oh my gosh!
get off what i'm gonna lure it back here you'll definitely do that use yourself as bait are you insane i'm used to this guy i know how to handle him
okay just jump straight into the treads yeah it's a great idea like oh my god yeah she won't run me over or anything Yeah, you tell him!
Okay, phase two.
Let's go.
He's really fast, actually.
Okay, so...
I can still stun or...
Do I get anything for doing it non-lethal?
I don't remember.
Like...
Oh my god!
Are you kidding me?
Where's my Mosin?
There we go.
That's hilarious.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I see him.
Oh,
gosh.
Okay, we can't do Kero-Tan.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
We can't get out of time, I'm so sorry.
I can't move.
Oh, wow.
These are pretty good.
Okay, nice.
That was crazy.
Holy cow.
Come and get me!
Nice!
Wait, this is so... this is not so bad at all actually.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is actually not so bad at all so far?
Okay.
Oops!
Ah!
Wait!
No!
Almost hit Eva!
She would be fine.
She'd be fine.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, no.
There we go.
I got stuck.
Oops.
That's fine.
Can I get some more supplies, actually?
Wait, that's gonna explode.
Oh,
wrong.
Wrong.
Oh, that was close.
I can't move!
So close!
Ouch!
Eva!
Do your distracting thing?
Your job?
The thing you were gonna do?
The thing you were supposed to be doing?
Yeah.
Wait, this was so easy.
easy this was so easy wow it was i remember i think he shot more missiles in the first game like in the original i mean
and uh and i could never shoot them down but in this game it's much easier to shoot them down
She said the thing.
His hair.
Vulcan, you're so funny.
Don't go bald.
Kulabara, Kulabara!
Oh, it's...
It's actually so gruesome.
Yeah, the bullets on him are like...
Fried by a bolt of lightning.
Yeah.
A fitting end.
It's finally over.
It's like fireworks.
Croc view.
You love to see it.
Just a little bit more.
Yeah.
The escape craft is just up ahead.
The weak.
We gotta
get...
They can fly?
Yeah!
They can!
I don't think they should be going this fast.
So loud, oh my gosh.
Death is more gruesome due to the added gourd.
Right, right.
Oh, my bad.
That's not what I meant to do.
Bullets are literally ripping them apart.
It's really sick.
Oh wait, I can still use this.
I'll try.
No, you guys act like these guys weren't floating earlier in the game.
They totally were.
It's only in one scene though, but they are.
They are.
Or something.
Or two.
Just keep shooting.
I got them.
Oh, so bad.
How many minkees does it take to shoot?
Oh my god, there's more of them.
Don't worry, I got him.
I can't get this one stinking guy.
But
you can't drive and shoot, right?
How are you still alive?
The last cobra.
Oh, we're fine, we're fine.
Don't worry.
I'll just shoot.
Oh my god, how am I so bad?
It's actually hilarious.
No way.
Oh my god.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh.
You're like so shielded.
Come on.
Let me get you.
Oh, we got him.
I think.
Oh my gosh.
No deaths.
No deaths!
Where are you?
Uh, wrong time?
Wrong time?
Oh, I didn't even equip it.
We got him.
Stop going up and down, please.
There we go.
We got him?
There's more?
Oh, my gosh.
Never-ending chase scene?
Wait, where are you?
I am shooting the log.
Wait, what's the log?
Oh, that's the log.
I got you?
Oh, there's more.
Oh, my gosh.
Of course there is.
This is the never-ending cutscene ever.
I won't let you live this time.
Oh, did I get Kero-Tan?
Wait, I got the guy.
You can't shoot.
You can shoot.
You can shoot and drive.
You're so talented.
Oh, my gosh.
You're the guy.
You're the one to do it.
Nice.
I'm getting better It only took like forever Oh there are more people Okay You're fine We're fine Everything's fine No one Right?
What do you mean right?
Oh
A jump?
Hold on tight
She's still far away Or
like her voice is really really far away In those cut scenes Because the camera's far away that's the same don't start celebrating yet we're leaking fuel oh you can see sorry my head's in the way my snout is so you know um keep your eyes on the road please crap
everything bad in video games happens because people don't keep their eyes on the road i'm just saying good thing we avoided that concussion because we had this sick helmet on every time it happens way too often oh boy oh no
eva eva we're okay eva eva
no How's it look?
Pretty bad.
Not a sensitive bone in your body.
Eva.
What about you, Snake?
I'm fine.
It's good to hear.
Am I naked, Miss?
You have to get away from here, Eva.
Let's go.
Sorry, I'm lagging a little.
Leave me.
Eva.
No.
The boss is waiting for you.
You have to go.
Give me a gun.
No, we're getting out of here.
Yeah.
We're still far away from the lake.
I'll never make it.
I can't believe this.
I never thought I'd see you act this week.
Oh.
What do you mean?
Listen to me, Eva.
We're doing this together.
No, you...
Eva, I need you.
Say that one more time We can't see her expression I need you I can't fly the wake By myself
So snake of him I guess I'd better help you out Yes please Oh gosh
He's eating her And then he's gonna eat me!
Oh my god!
You're lucky to have me.
Girl, how are you standing?
Bandage, Snake!
Yeah!
Oh wait.
It might be time to observe Eva.
Snake, can you hear me?
Paramedic, thank God.
Eva's been seriously hurt.
Wow, this rain ASMR?
Luckily, I think her organs are all intact, but...
Calm down, soon.
This is nice.
Calm down.
You'll both be fine as long as you get the proper emergency treatment, but you're the only one who can do this.
Understand?
So you've got to calm down.
Right.
Okay.
Now let's open up the Survival Viewer and treat the injury.
Do you have supplies with you?
I'm running kind of short.
Then by switching the Survival Viewer over to Eva, you can treat her wounds too.
Now get to work.
and snake yeah i'm pretty sure you know this already but if you don't have enough supplies for the both of you your wounds come first um do you get my meaning snake you've still got a mission to complete yeah i know what i have to do snake like this oh no oh it sounded so good though i think we have enough for both of us my wound is out yeah we Freddy got a short,
sir.
We're bleeding.
A bandage.
Disinfectment.
Bone fracture.
Oh, no.
We only have max supplies.
Whatever will we do?
We're only completely maxed out.
Oh, there we go.
Whatever will we do?
She don't look so good.
Oh yeah girl.
Where you get them bones from?
Oh nice bones on this body.
Yeah girl.
I like that they're like kind of they look like ectoplasm right?
That pelvic burn, I know, I know.
Oh wait, what is it?
Medical history, here it is.
What's a proctitis?
I feel like I asked that before.
Oh no, tummy horrid, she got a little stomach ache.
Oh no.
Electrical burn, hypoxia.
Broken nail, where?
She got poisoned and then it broke her nail.
It's so sad.
It's when your butt hurts.
Oh, no.
Blow sustained.
She got a cold.
Another tummy ache.
Tummy ache.
And her ear infection.
Oh, ew, ew.
A cavity.
Uh-oh.
Bronchitis.
I hope you're having a good day.
Hi, eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Do you have bronchitis?
Does Mike Tyson have proctitis?
Slate paralysis!
Oh my gosh, I'm haunting her.
Tick-borne encephalitis.
Frostbite!
My girl has been through it.
What's she eating?
Oh yeah, she eats good.
This girl!
That's that me espresso.
They're a tummy whore a lot.
Look at this.
Gorgonzola cream fettuccini.
Rat.
Chinese almond jelly.
European rabbit.
Actually, that kind of sounds fancy.
Yabloko maloko sorbet.
Vampire bat.
This is messed up.
Tona Seabream Amberjack Sashimi with Plum Garnish Reticulated Python This is messed up Where's the one that says like she got the boob job Electrical burn Lower back pain Her boobs are just too big
pass it.
Wait, which one is it?
I pass it again.
What is it called?
Below stomach ache.
There's a couple.
Oh, there it is.
I can't.
Wow, I'm so blind.
Breast enhancement.
They look good.
They look We're bleeding.
We'll sew that up.
We'll stop at it.
We'll put that bandage on.
She's bleeding out, and I'm looking at her boobies.
Sutsure, bleeding, bandage.
Are you okay?
Can you walk?
Yeah.
I think so.
Can you be quiet?
Because now it's an escort mission.
Because for some reason, Kojima loves these.
She is so...
Like, she has nothing on her face, and we're just dirty, dirty, dirty.
She's so clean, pristine.
Drop the skincare routine, queen.
She's so pretty.
It's different from the Mouser.
When you're using a two-hand grip, you have to be careful where you put your hands or your fingers or get burned to exhaust gas from the cylinder gap.
hungry actually why'd you do that huh felt a little influence to start twirling your guns about wonder why can't stop thinking about them Wow hello snake are you alright pizza I want pizza so bye what about Eva I healed her up she can manage good snake you'll take the lead and break through the enemy's line of defense.
Your Fujoshi showing, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
If you lie on your belly, she'll lie down as well.
Okay.
If you slip and fall off a cliff, she'll follow right behind.
Now that this playthrough is nearing its head, I have the urge to play some MGS while modding and starting a fight.
Head to the lake along with Eva.
That's so good.
Does she crouch walk?
Like, important question.
It doesn't look like she does.
Do you know what you're doing?
What, a girl, I just started getting started.
Chill out.
Oh, call Eva.
Are you stupid or something?
Why are you so mean to me?
I'm taking care of you!
Luckily, um...
Our stamina...
Actually, I'm gonna eat these.
I'm gonna eat these.
Because of the crock cap?
No.
No way.
There's no way.
Yeah.
Delish.
Oh, look at them swimming!
Let's get rid of some things in my backpack.
Like, we don't need this anymore.
We don't need that anymore.
We could do the stun grenade, though, just in case.
Ah, we'll put a book down, maybe.
We could also...
Oh, okay.
We can throw that down, maybe, too.
Do you have a death wish?
Why is...
Why?
Stop being such a hater.
Okay?
Wait, am I going the right way?
This way?
Eva!
Eva, I will continue on without you.
Oh, whoa, you can see the flame.
It's so cool.
Eva, get down, girl.
Eva!
What's wrong with you?
Oh, well.
Come on, get serious.
Oh, why is she such a hater?
Real question.
We're gonna start coming in.
Here they are.
You've been using the croc cap the entire mission and now she complains.
Stop trying to act all cool.
Like, you know what's...
We're soldiers with 179 IQ!
The Johnny squad.
Everybody's Johnny.
Actually, my camo is like super bad.
Let's see.
I think it would be better if we were in a crocodile suit.
Everybody else agree?
Say I.
Okay.
Good job.
Glad we're in agreement.
Why?
What?
What happened?
Wait, what happened?
Did Eva get caught?
No kidding.
Oh, I have my fork out.
Don't worry, I'll fork him.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Eva.
Eva, I'm really disappointed in you.
Eva, this is a no kill run!
Come on, Eva.
Come on.
I thought if I crawl... Oh wait, she can't crawl.
That's right.
Or she can't crouch walk.
I'm so hungry.
Okay, fine.
I'll give you...
Uh...
How do I give this to you?
Oh.
Eat Eva.
pacifist run dead no it wasn't me it wasn't me come on come on eva they're they're like right behind you girl i need you to i really need you to crawl food okay you'll get you you will get food if you if you work come on wait am i going the right way yes i'm trying to get her close to me like over here like away from everything Okay,
come here.
Come here.
There you go.
All right, I'll give you food.
I'll give you food.
Oh, you gotta be closer.
Come here.
Do you know what you're doing?
Oh my God, don't get up.
Don't get up.
I'm gonna give you the bat.
This tastes like crap.
How?
Use this to buy you a happy meal.
Alright, come on.
Oh my gosh, Eva.
Keep going.
Eva, we're almost there.
This is the way, right?
I'm almost positive.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ow, ow, ow.
Ow, ow, ow, my aim.
No, Eva, it's us!
We're pacifists run!
Oh, my aim!
Please!
I still got him.
No!
No, we're knocking him out.
We're not killing him.
I'm right here.
Snake.
Come here.
Come here, little Eva.
Come on.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel no sense of urgency here.
Oh, Eva is not near me.
Damn, girl.
Eva!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh my gosh, are you okay?
Come here.
My gosh.
Wait, how do I, uh...
Oh, I was gonna try and turn off the...
I wanna just see her, you know?
Okay.
Um, you have a bullet watch.
I can get that out.
I can help you.
Uh, we're disinfecting.
We're...
We're suturing.
Oh, no, we're not.
We're bandaging.
Oh, we're stifting it.
There we go.
You need ibuprofen.
Come on, girl.
This way.
Keep on going.
Which way?
Okay, we're almost there.
No, it's right here.
It's right here, Eva, please.
Eva, please.
They're going to be like, you can't go without Eva.
Come on, Eva.
Come on, girl.
Oh, my gosh.
Again.
You.
Bastard!
What are you?
Girl, get over here.
Girl, girl, girl!
Eva, are you okay?
Come on, come on.
Hey, it's me.
Come
on.
Eva.
Eva, you're not...
Eva, you're in really bad shape.
Okay, come on.
I could see QC you.
Why?
Oh, Eva.
She's all...
You guys, it's not her fault.
She's all silly about things right now.
Medical history, gunshot wound times fifth.
She's all silly right now.
It's not her fault.
It's not her fault, okay?
Oh my gosh.
Badish.
I'm gonna run out of everything because of her.
I'm looking fine.
Just a little bloody.
That's okay.
Okay, come on.
Are you stupid or something?
Come on.
No!
God damn!
Oh, he got down.
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
I wish I could leave things to you.
But you're just that stupid.
Come on.
Eva, come on.
This way.
Please.
Please, Eva.
They're going to say you can't go without Eva.
The lake is just over that cliff.
Eva should be able to climb it if you help her.
Keep her close to you.
I'm trying.
Come here.
Come on.
We're walking!
Please!
Uh-oh, wait.
Am I doing the next cutscene in this outfit?
Oops.
Can CQ see her?
Because sometimes when a man and a woman feel a certain way about each other...
Yeah, they want to wrestle.
I get it.
I know, I know.
You're lucky you're so cute, Eva.
Oh, there's still more.
Oh my gosh, I forgot.
Oh, geez.
Okay, okay.
Oh, me?
When did I get shot?
Uh...
Oh, I didn't see that guy at all.
Where are you guys going?
Oh.
You don't get out of my way.
I don't know each other.
Where?
Eva?
Eva, you can.
Eva, actually, I don't know where the shots are coming from.
I'm like so lost.
Oh.
What?
Huh?
Oh?
Where were they coming from?
Wait, where were they coming from?
For real?
Come on!
Eva!
No, no, no, no!
My legs won't move anymore.
Do I need a CQCU?
Is that what you need?
me to do?
Come on.
You won't let me.
Eva!
Oh my gosh.
Where?
Actually.
It's like...
Where?
The trees?
Eva, do you need some food?
Oh, sorry.
I'll give you a bag.
She's so blind.
I literally can't say it.
I'm sorry.
Bush on the left.
Ah, I see him.
How is that blind?
Don't be a jerk.
He was literally hiding.
No, come on, Eva.
We gotta go.
Girl, we gotta go.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Come on.
All right.
Pick you up.
Okay, here we go.
Onwards.
All right.
Don't worry about it.
She might drown a little.
Okay.
This will make her really refreshed.
Probably.
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
Yes.
Mud facial.
Exactly, exactly.
Okay, come on, Eva.
We're gonna go this way.
I'm gonna get a little snack real quick, though.
Don't mind me.
Where's that snake?
Here you are.
I got something.
Uh.
Just a little snack for the road.
Um.
I'll see.
anything else.
You're just kidding.
Alright, Deva.
Come on.
Eva is starving.
Eva is asleep.
I see some more rustling.
If I get to eat, then she can have whatever I have in my inventory.
It's a win-win.
What was here, anyway?
there was something here for sure i saw the bushes unless it was them birds
are the guys still around
i don't see anybody do you guys there's some rustling not a guy is it no thermal so true Roo.
Ah hi!
I can get his butt from here.
I can't get his butt from here.
I didn't.
Uh.
Nowhere?
Oh no, she's awake.
Oh no.
How are you?
Oh, there we go.
Oh.
Saw another guy.
Where do you run to?
You want some food, Eva?
You want some food?
Come here.
I can grab.
Yeah, Eva, shut up, please.
We'll give you this mushroom.
My legs.
My leg!
Shhh!
This one is tasted terrible.
Try it.
What did you give me?
Try this one.
I'm gonna puke.
I do need some of these.
I've lost my appetite.
There was a guy.
Definitely lost him, though.
There was a third...
I saw him running.
Don't know where he is now.
That's okay.
Alright.
We continue onwards, and we need to go over there, I think.
Yep.
Oh, there he is.
Ah!
I'm over here.
Where the hell are you?
My camel's too good.
Wait, where the hell is she?
Eva!
Oh my god, come here.
Come here.
Oh, she's so stupid.
Come here, please.
Desperate times call for desperate measures.
Even her snoring is loud.
Yeah, yeah, right there.
My snake.
Oh, that's so good.
Yeah, right there.
Oh, boss.
That feels so good.
We love a bye queen.
Right there.
Fido.
That feels so good.
Fido!
The dog.
Yeah, Strange Love has some words about that.
I think she needs to wake up.
up though for we can just stomp on her what the dog doing wait I want to since we have her oh wait we could just take it out that's kind of fun all right wake up nice let's go actually am I in the right spot yeah come here come here
we made it want to stay croc for this yeah it's fine I'll still be sad probably
we're committed
guys this is it
come on snake come on snake
We made it.
But now you can run.
Yeah.
Over there.
Wow.
So inconspicuous.
It's the boss, isn't it?
I'll go get the wig ready to take off.
Okay.
Right.
I'll leave you two alone.
But come back in one piece, okay?
Promise me!
One piece.
Life's end.
Isn't it beautiful?
It's almost tragic.
When life ends, it gives off a final lingering aroma.
Light is but a farewell gift from the darkness to those on their way to die.
I've been waiting, Snake.
for a long time, waiting for your birth, your growth, and the finality of today.
Boss, why are you doing this?
Why?
To make the world one again.
The world used to be whole.
But with the end of the Second World War, the philosophers began to fight amongst themselves, and the world was torn apart.
The Cobra's my comrades who trained and fought alongside me were torn apart as well.
The foibles of politics and a march of time can turn friends into enemies just as easily as the wind changes.
Ridiculous, isn't it?
Yesterday's ally becomes today's opposition.
And this Cold War?
Think back.
When I was leading the Cobra's, America and Russia were fighting together.
Now, consider whether America and Russia will still be enemies in the 21st century.
Somehow I doubt it.
Enemies change along with the times, the flow of the ages, and we soldiers are forced to play along.
I didn't raise you and shape you into the man you are today, just so we could face each other in battle.
skills aren't meant to be used to hurt friends.
So then what is an enemy?
Is there such a thing as an absolute timeless enemy?
There is no such thing, and never has been.
And the reason is that our enemies are human beings like us.
They can only be our enemies in relative terms.
So pretty.
The world must be made whole again.
the philosophers must be reunited I will devote my skills to that purpose and with the Colonel's money I will achieve that end just as I once created the Cobras they are my family they were I may no longer be able to bear children but I still have a family it was November 1st 1951 I was in the Nevada desert participating in atomic testing.
The name Nevada is derived from Spanish.
Covered in snow, white as snow.
This music.
And snow is exactly what I saw in that Nevada desert.
It froze my blood white.
Snake, you were an atomic test subject, weren't you?
on Bikini Atoll.
That's part of the reason I was drawn to you.
You and I are alike.
We're both slowly being eaten away by the karma of others.
We'll never have the chance to die peacefully of old age.
We have no tomorrow.
But we can still have hope for the future.
In 1960, I saw a vision of the ideal future, from space.
Three years earlier, the Soviet Union had succeeded in launching Sputnik, the first man-made satellite in history, into orbit.
This came as a huge shock to the United States.
In response, America threw everything it had into its own manned spaceflight project, the Mercury program.
even as the Soviets seemed poised to send their first man into space America was still experimenting with chimpanzees and rockets the government wanted human data so they secretly decided to send a human being into space I was the one they chose at the time they didn't have the technology to block out cosmic rays.
And whoever they sent up would inevitably be exposed to heavy radiation.
That's why they chose me.
After all, I'd already been irradiated once.
Of course, you won't find any of this in the history books.
I could see the planet as it appeared from space.
That's when it finally hit me.
Space exploration is nothing but another game in the power struggle between the U.S.
and the USSR.
Politics, economics, The arms race, they're all just arenas for meaningless competition.
I'm sure you can see that, but the Earth itself has no boundaries.
No East, no West, no Cold War.
And the irony of it is, the United States and the Soviet Union are spending billions on their space programs and the missile race, only to arrive at the same conclusion.
In the 21st century, everyone will be able to see that we are all just inhabitants of a little celestial body called Earth.
A world without communism or capitalism, that is the world I wanted to see.
But reality continued to betray me.
Boss.
In 1961, I was sent to...
I know.
Tobias de Cucinos.
It was part of a CIA-sponsored invasion under the guise of taking Cuban exiles back to their country.
But the U.S.
government betrayed them.
Our weakening president held back their air support.
Defenseless, the exiles were annihilated by the Cuban army.
All I could do was watch in silence.
by the very country i'd sacrificed so much for by the very government i dedicated my life to defending i was driven from the surface world and i went underground what then two years ago i faced the sorrow my old comrade in battle he was my friend there he is but one of us had to die left with no choice he chose paper the sorrow gave his life for me what is there is no enmity between us one must live and one must die that was the mission the ones who gave me that mission were the philosophers early in the 20th century the true holders of power in the united states the republic of china and the newly formed soviet over like that gathered together oh i'm blocking the little kid be known as the wise men's committee the secret pact they formed there marked the beginning of the philosophers but the last of the original members died in the 1930s after that the organization began to run out of control and the wise men's committee degenerated into a mere shell of its former self the
philosophers of today have no sense of good Their influence extends to countries and organizations involved in every aspect of every war.
I'm the little kid now.
I'm baby boss.
That's how they operate.
The sacrifices of war cause a shift in the times.
This shift leads to renewed conflict and in turn triggers the next war.
Like a nuclear chain reaction, each conflict sparks countless others, forming an endless spiral that will continue on for eternity.
Do you understand what I'm saying, Snake?
By consuming me and you, the Philosophers intend to keep that cycle going forever.
Oh, there she is.
It was my father who explained all of this to me.
He was one of them.
You see, I am the last remaining child of the Philosophers.
Little baby.
but after he revealed the truth my father was killed by that same shapeless formless organization I got back and my father isn't the only thing the philosophers have taken for me in June of 1944 the Cobras and I took part in the landing at Normandy we'd been given a top secret mission to locate and destroy enemy V-2 rocket installations.
So cool.
I was pregnant at the time.
The sorrow was the father.
I gave birth on the field of battle.
A beautiful baby boy.
But my child was snatched away from me by the philosophers.
I'll never forgive them.
Actually, maybe he wouldn't be the crazy man he is a day if he wasn't snatched away you know what maybe look at the scar this is proof that I was once a mother botched job in my child for my country there is nothing left inside me now nothing at all no hatred not even regret and yet sometimes at night I can still feel the pain creeping up inside me,
slithering through my body like a snake.
Seasection by the worst surgeon ever, for real.
Thanks.
Thanks for listening to me.
I feel content.
Snake.
Commence the operation.
It has sex.
I raised you.
I loved you.
I've given you weapons, taught you techniques, endowed you with knowledge.
I could just listen to the boss talk, you know?
There is nothing more for me to give you.
All that's left for you to take is my life.
By your own hand.
One must die, and one must live.
No victory, no defeat.
The survivor will carry on the fight.
It is our destiny.
My voice is so nice.
The one who survives will inherit the title of boss.
And the one who inherits the title of boss will face an existence of endless battle.
I'll give you 10 minutes.
Oh gosh.
In 10 minutes, Migs will come and bomb the hell out of this place.
If you can beat me in less than 10 minutes, you'll be able to escape in time.
Let's make this the greatest 10 minutes of our lives, Jack.
Boss?
You're a soldier.
Finish your mission.
Prove your loyalty.
Yes, she is, Pearl from SpongeBob.
Face me.
Ah!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, are you out of your mind?
Sorry, I was trying to change.
Oh my gosh, wait.
She really gets you.
Heads up.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying.
Look, we're covered in the white paddles.
Stop.
It actually does change.
No!
That's so...
Wee!
That's so wee.
Alright.
How we want to do this.
We can't see QC, though.
I could be a scientist.
There...
What is the...
There is a white one, but I didn't get it, I suppose.
We'll go with the chocolate chip.
Gold, yeah.
I gotta be gold.
Wait.
The iPatch is also gold.
a child it's so funny i mean yeah of course it would be but it's so funny um we'll go chocolate chip i think that might be our best option oh wait snow there it is duh yeah i was like i was confused if i had grabbed it or not um we won't go with spider i don't want our we don't have any food or anything so equip the book Would the Tuxedo make good camo?
It would if we could CQC in it.
I beat the game on European Extreme.
No special items.
I feel very accomplished.
And I beat the boss with just CQC.
Let's go, Charlie!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'll miss having...
Yeah.
Ah!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Boss, please.
Boss, let me just get ready, please.
Oh, gosh.
Don't look at me like that.
Oh!
I'm sorry!
Oh, my gosh.
Why am I so bad at the CQC?
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna die for real.
Thanks, she's so good.
Done.
That's okay.
Oh my gosh, I wasn't ready at all.
The Q is harder this time.
Golly.
Okay.
She called me pathetic, though.
That was kind of awesome.
Oh my gosh, I'm still the croc!
Are you out of your mind?
Oh my gosh.
Please, please!
Okay, okay.
All right.
Not good.
Oh, no.
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
We're fine.
I have a bone fracture.
No biggie.
They changed the CQC timing.
Where'd she go?
Oh my gosh, my tummy is growling like crazy right now.
There she is.
I also need to turn it down just a little bit.
You gonna come out?
Tessinka camp, you've only heard about in the middle of battle, was it very small?
Where is she?
She gonna come out?
Which tree was it?
This one?
Yes?
I think?
I might be crazy.
Who is this one?
Right?
Boss?
I need to be aggressive because we don't have much time.
I made the CQC easier?
If you just let the boss beat you up until you get the slowdown, the prompt, okay.
Oh, there she is.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I was at the wrong tree the whole time.
That's so embarrassing.
So slow down, I see QC her.
Wait.
I don't know why I keep unequipping my gun.
I'm doing it because I'm like, oh, I don't want her to see me.
You know what I mean?
Oh, there she is.
Okay.
She went behind one of these trees.
This one?
One of them.
This one.
Shoot the exclamation point.
Is that like the...
Whoop!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, goes thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I have gotten stronger.
Actually, I...
I don't know.
know why this feels much easier.
Oh, I lost her though.
I actually lost her.
Oh, there she is.
I didn't lose her.
Why is she not looking at me?
Okay, so slow down.
Never mind, I didn't get to slow down.
Okay, we're dumb.
Oh, nope.
Okay, I'm dumb.
I don't know how to do this.
I don't
CQC only please.
Yeah, we'll be here for five hours.
Oh, the disrespect.
There we go.
I would love to otherwise.
There she is.
I'm surprised the music hasn't started though.
I don't want to get her before the music starts!
I lost her.
I think
it's because I can crouch.
It makes it...
The crash walk makes everything so much easier.
Ugh!
Ah!
Gosh!
Oh my god.
Run, run, run, run.
Oh shoot.
Don't come.
Oh
my gosh.
Please.
Please, boss.
Boss, be nice to me.
I'm your son.
Oh my gosh, I can't.
Oh, hello.
Gosh.
Gunshot wound.
In my fight?
Oh, bone fracture.
Of course.
Of course, of course.
Yeah, I can't have it equipped or she...
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to use a life heal.
I do have it in here, right?
Yeah.
Life medicine.
Why not?
Oh, please.
Move.
No.
Uh-oh.
I'm out.
I do have some grenades, y'all.
Where'd she throw the ammo?
I can't open my face.
Oh my gosh.
I completely forgot.
I don't have it.
Oh well.
Oh there she is.
I'm not going to be able to get her.
I got her.
Oh she's covered in drag tarts.
No!
Oh, please, ma'am!
Please!
Where's all my stuff?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my stuff.
Where's all my stuff?
You're so rude!
Oh, I found something.
Oh my gosh, I found one thing.
Where is it?
Where'd it go?
Oh my gosh.
What do you mean?
I have to get it first.
Where's my gun?
This is pathetic!
There!
Is that my gun?
I didn't even get a chance to CQC.
I was trying to grab my gun!
No!
Where's my gun?
This is so bad.
I don't want to...
Oh, it's a cut.
Time is running out.
Thermals.
Oh, you're so right.
Wait.
And you know what?
I'm also gonna do.
Please, no.
Please.
Let me get it, please.
No, don't throw it.
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna live.
I'm not gonna live.
I'm not gonna live
To survive Oh shit
Take this keep it safe
We're rich
I didn't even see like a slowdown to do the secrecy.
I really didn't.
You're a wonderful man.
Like I didn't know when at all to click.
Kill me.
Kill me now.
Do it.
I think maybe...
After, I could try and, like, practice.
There's only room for one boss and one snake.
Happens during the animation.
The whole thing is an animation.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh.
Whig.
The fact that he's covered in blood, too, kind of makes it so messed up.
No, not our words.
Wee!
I hate...
Well, no, wait.
I was gonna say I hate this next part, but no, no time to be sad.
We ha- wait, you guys, what should I pick?
The left or the right gun!
No time to be sad!
Ready to go, Snake?
This boy is coming back!
Oh, Snake.
someone give him a towel are you okay left
I pick left every time
I do get to keep it if I pick the right one that's true that is true okay here comes Fat-ass Ocelot to bring down the plane.
I told you you could trust me.
There can only three people can be on this ship.
Snake!
Ocelot.
We're not done yet.
Oh no.
No, you're never done.
Open up!
Damn!
Oh my god!
Don't do it.
Don't do it!
One of
us needs to get off!
Come on!
Eva, jump!
I'm asleep.
Just kidding.
We're too heavy.
Try to remember some of the basics of CQC.
That's stance.
Not good.
Uh-oh.
Ah, Salat, you're too fat!
They're just dancing at this point.
They love it.
I've picked up a few new moves.
It doesn't feel right to shoot an unarmed man, but I'll get over it.
Eva!
Oh!
What do you say to one last showdown?
Yeah,
god they're just doing it.
The ship is the we're going down we're crashing but my ship be sailing The plane is you know the plane is the ship but also you know did I get it Talk
What's your name?
Snake?
No.
Not that name.
You're not a snake, and I'm not an Ocelot.
We're men with names.
My name is Adamska.
What's yours?
John.
Very well, John.
Plain name.
But I won't forget it.
John Snake.
Come on.
Guys, which one should I pick?
Oh my god, am I... I'm like dying for real?
Pick one up already Pick one up already Pick one Have you lost your nerve?
No What are you doing?
Oh Ah Pick one up already Right I think I did the left last time So we'll go with the right I think I did left the last time, so...
Yeah, this is the quote-unquote lore-accurate choice.
He got me.
Just kidding.
It's a blank!
Oh, that was fun.
I love we just... That's not even his gun.
It's evas.
Just doing it for the love of the game.
Why did you even come back?
Because you're obsessed.
So we meet again.
John.
It's too good.
Snake.
Give me a hand.
Hold.
I love us a lot.
Come on, hold on.
Eva was just fighting for her life over there while we're dancing.
Oh, the blood's gone.
We made it.
Yeah, you sure did.
I know.
Oh no.
Mix!
You're so right.
He did chase down Snake to fire a blank and have a laugh before jumping out.
He's the...
There's no way out.
He's the toughest guy ever.
We've come too far to let them stop us now.
Those things have got to be all right.
Love can only move on the battlefield!
They're gonna shoot us down!
We were so close!
Weapons systems on now.
Locked on target.
I need more water.
You were great, Eva.
Thanks.
She's so pretty.
This is control.
Stand by for a direct order from the chairman.
Alt-19, return to base immediately.
Do you read me?
This is a direct order from...
Was she good?
Return to base immediately.
Alt-19, do you copy it?
Thank you, Robin.
Stock strings!
Thanks for the tag, get that!
Look!
The Migs are turning back!
Woo!
Oh my god.
Anime moment.
Well done, Snake.
The MiG's disengaged.
Most likely under orders from Khrushchev.
Is this his way of helping us?
Who knows?
Maybe he didn't want things to get messier than they already are.
Or maybe he just wanted us to owe him one.
The important thing is, you made it out alive.
As long as Khrushchev is with us, I don't think they'll be coming after you.
It should be smooth sailing all the way to Alaska.
I'm sending someone out to Galena Bay to meet you.
To meet me.
Don't mind Teen Titans, Robin, VA telling Russian pilot gods to stand up.
Don't keep them waiting.
Wait, I didn't even realize that the pilot was gods.
Gotta go dog sledding.
Yep.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh, it didn't save.
It didn't auto save right before the boss fight.
Oh no.
I wanted to go back and try, you know?
Oh no, I should have saved myself.
Oh my gosh, imagine if I had...
Well, I guess...
If I had failed...
I wonder where it would have put us.
Go back to the KGB.
What do you want me to do?
Did you ever think about coming back to America?
I can't go back.
I've left America behind me.
But you saved this country.
I didn't do it alone.
And I still owe you a dinner.
Oh my gosh, no way.
Is that part of your mission too?
Or is it an order?
Or is it an invitation?
Or a proposal?
She's so close.
Oh!
I don't take orders from anyone, though.
I see your eyes.
I feel your pain.
I feel your sadness inside of me.
Whose house is this?
The wine!
I hope they're not mad.
Is this like an Airbnb?
The only one.
Afraid to fall in love.
Dance with me.
Walk this away.
Yeah.
How is he gonna get home?
Wait.
Wait, how is he gonna call someone to pick him up?
It tastes like wild beast.
The last thing I ate was...
What was it?
It was that snake on the ground.
Now I'm eating you.
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
Oh my gosh.
Kew!
We're a little beat up.
A little bit.
We cleaned up the wine.
Video.
game kissing still awkward oh yeah we just uh it's like i feel like watching these scenes with you guys is like watching a sexy scene in a movie with my parents the snake in the book of genesis in that story it was eve who was tempted by the snake in the garden of eden but this time around wow vein these are veins i know they go crazy
he's a little he's a little beat up that's my fault oh why is he he's like duck lips he's like we are your parents yeah I get too embarrassed watching sexy scenes in front of you guys good
morning snake good morning snake oh first of all I have to apologize oh here comes the mysterious music i'm not a kgb spy and i never worked for the nsa i'm an agent of the people's republic of china for the general hq second department of the people's liberation army it was all a lie i tricked you and i'm sorry she
was a double triple spy the philosophers still exist in China too you see my mission was to find out where Volgan was hiding the philosophers legacy and steal it so I infiltrated his base as a KGB spy the two NSA codebreakers who defected in 1960 were actually both men the real Adam never showed up at the meeting place.
I wonder why.
Saving me the trouble of having to eliminate him.
I sneaked in by pretending I was Eva.
And you and Sokolov and Volgan, you all believed me.
The philosopher's legacy was originally held in common between the US, Soviet Union, and China.
We couldn't let the Russians and the Americans take it all for themselves.
The Chinese government had its eye on the legacy too.
I got the film containing the legacy.
Oh my god.
And also the nuclear missile launched data from the Shagohad.
Five years ago the Soviet Union stopped supplying us with nuclear weapons technology.
Since then China's Leon Don easing hydrogen bomb and space rocket projects have fallen behind.
But with this data our country will be able to develop its own nukes.
We'll create a deterrent force to rival those of the US and Soviet Union everything has gone according to plan thanks to your help my poor guy is just being used all the time all the time I'm an agent of the philosophers a graduate of one of their charm schools I was raised in a joint US-Soviet Chinese facility to become a sleeper agent I could I could become a little more job there were collecting children from all over the world As a result,
I'm indistinguishable from a native-born American.
So it didn't surprise me when you and Vulgan couldn't tell the difference.
But she knew right from the beginning.
She knew because before the war, she was at one of the philosopher's schools, too, as an instructor.
The boss was the only one I couldn't fool.
She was the only one who knew I was a fake.
Cut them a recording and a check-in.
She told me everything.
I like why did she open her heart to me like that you're already a graduate I couldn't understand it but now I think I do snake she wanted you to know the truth she chose me to tell you that's why she saved my life I've lied to you so many times but not this time my orders from the government So many times.
Okay.
And to eliminate everyone who knew the truth about what happened.
In other words, I'm supposed to kill you.
But I can't do it.
Not because we loved each other.
And not because you saved my life.
But because I made a promise to the boss.
And I intend to keep it.
Thank you for the raid!
This is mega spoilers for the raid.
Metal Gear Solid 3 just in case anybody wanted to play.
Thank you so much.
We just live, Snake.
She puts the glasses on.
She looks like Maddie.
Oh my gosh.
So pretty.
What if you weren't listening?
Oh no.
Snake, listen to me.
she didn't betray the united states no far from it she was a hero who died for her country she carried out her mission knowing full well what was going to happen self-sacrifice because that was her duty
hi tyan
who's she Oh my goodness, who are you?
You are above even the boss.
I hereby award you the title of Big Boss.
It gets me every time.
Sorry, it's so funny.
You are a true patriot.
Uh...
Even
now he's thinking about him.
I don't shake that guy's hand.
Don't do it.
It's nasty.
Yeah, scowl at us.
That guy will remember this.
You know, unit like Fox in the army, someone like him to handle our top secret sneaking missions for us a man who combines the qualities of a soldier and an agent the boss's defection was a ruse set up by the US government it was all a big drama staged by Washington so they could get their hands on the philosophers legacy and the boss was the star of the show they played it so that they could get the legacy that Colonel Vulcan inherited and destroy the Shagohad at the same time time.
Only a legendary hero like the boss could have earned Vulcan's trust, finding out where the philosophers like his maiden was to be her greatest mission.
Everything was going according to plan.
But then something happened that no one could have predicted.
Colonel Vulcan fired an American-made nuclear warhead at Sokolov's research facility.
Khrushchev demanded that the U.S.
government provide proof that it wasn't involved.
They couldn't just abort the operation to steal the legacy.
So the operation itself was greatly expanded and revised.
The authorities in Washington knew that in order to prove its innocence, they'd have to get rid of the boss, and that one of their own would have to do the job.
The public couldn't be allowed to find out about it, not ever.
This, they concluded, would be the best way to keep the whole whole thing under wraps.
We're his best overalls.
The boss wouldn't be allowed to come back home alive.
And she wouldn't be allowed to kill herself.
Her life would be ended by her most beloved disciple.
Oh, the music gets me every time.
That was the way the government wanted it.
That was the mission she was given.
And she had no choice but to carry it out.
Her death at your hands was a duty she had to fulfill.
Out of duty, she turned her back on her own comrades.
A lesser woman would have been crushed by such a burden.
The taint of disgrace will follow her to her grave.
Future generations will revile her.
In America as a despicable traitor with no sense of honor.
And in Russia as a monster who unleashed a nuclear catastrophe.
She will go down in official history as a war criminal.
And no one will ever understand her.
That's true.
That was her final mission.
That is true.
No one will ever understand her.
And like a true soldier, she saw it through to the end.
But I think she wanted you, of all people, to know the truth.
She wanted to live on in your memory Not as a soldier I think it's kind of dangerous to leave a god here I guess kind of public We will understand her She was forbidden to tell you herself And that's why she told me
Snake History will never know what she did.
No one will ever learn the truth.
Her story, her debriefing, will endure only in your heart.
Sorry.
Everything she did, she did for her country.
She sacrificed her life and her honor for her native land.
She was a real hero.
She was a true patriot.
I
don't want to see him.
I don't want to see him crying.
Man.
1970, the U.S.
branch of philosophers changes its name to the Patriot.
Let's...
Big Boss establishes Foxhound!
72, the laser photon!
Ah, blub project is developed!
The sons of Big Boss are born.
Oh.
always gets me too afterwards man
oh is there always subtitles
they'll tell you where to go
that's new right yeah that's interesting
That's okay, DMCA.
That's okay.
I'd rather us hear it.
All of my Metal Gear streams get copyright anyway for music.
Oh, Robin Atkins Allen!
Yeah, there he is.
I've got something in my throat.
I need to be alone.
Oh, original style.
You've got a way to kill Setting research
I can't say offset feed, no it's okay, thank you though You'd better wait to shine They'll tell you what is yours
It never feels good.
Oh, it always feels so bad.
It always feels really bad.
Thank
you guys for the super chastening gift.
Thank you.
There's a hole inside my boat.
stay afloat for the summer i didn't ask um who's if anyone had not watched or played mgs3 before if this is your first time seeing the ending
me it is you have not oh good There's a few people here then.
First time!
Never played any Metal Gear game before.
The 3DS version!
3DS version is great because you can crouch walk in that one.
Tomo Kazu Fukushima!
Absolutely good, yeah.
It's never been better to be a Metal Gear fan.
It's pretty great, yeah.
Chris Zimmerman!
Chris Zimmerman, the goal.
Oh my gosh, she's crazy.
Oh wait.
You better wait so far.
It's pretty great right now.
They'll tell you where to go.
But they won't.
experience through friends and you oh that's fine too yeah yeah oh my gosh thank you so much for the thank you this was so fine though wow it definitely feels like a fresh experience but then also so you know and they're using this song which is crazy to me because um this song kind of got changed it got in trouble because of plagiarism oh my gosh thank you for another 50 oh my gosh thank you thank you thank you so the fact that they're able to use this song is really really awesome it's like the song whenever i love the new little gear theme but this is like the theme you know so it feels really good to hear it Even in like a new game.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, it hurts though.
It really hurts to hear.
Shoshi, your wallet, please.
But thank you.
Time to go watch the MGS4 VOD now.
Thank you.
Got Foxhound rank, let's go!
Snake Eater!
It's killing me.
It's killing me!
Oh my god!
Oh!
So good.
She snake on my eater.
No, stop.
Yes, Grozny Grad and the Grannon Research Facility have both sort of wiped out without a trace.
No, sir.
I understand, sir, but they were necessary sacrifices.
Yes, sir.
Yes, the CIA has taken care of the boss themselves.
No, sir.
will be satisfied yes sir Khrushchev is finished no sir your time is finally arrived yes sir yes the American president is relying on us to keep a lid on the whole affair you've got him by the balls it should make a valuable Trump card in future negotiations yes sir yes chief director of course I'll keep the KGP formed time to make a second call this guy is this ocelot yes this is ocelot
yes it's me yes sir the boss has accomplished her mission first Metal Gear stream the philosopher's legacy is now safely with us well technically America's hands it's the very start of the timeline so it's It's not a terrible place to start.
With this money.
Yes, the philosophers can finally be revived.
Thank you for the pink, you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
The film we handed the Chinese was a fake.
Peking must be in an uproar right about now.
I'm afraid so.
Only half the money has made it back to the United States.
The KGB must still have part of the legacy.
Dun dun.
Yes, the weapon has been reduced to ashes.
That's right.
Grozny Grad has been obliterated by the Davy Crockett we brought in as well.
Grozny Grad!
Yes, that was the boss's work too.
Speaking of which, I've obtained something from Granin that you might find interesting.
This is so messy.
It's a revolutionary new nuclear attack system.
Uh-oh.
might just come in handy someday oh yes we have John I mean snake to thank for that sorry Khrushchev believe it as well he can't he can't stop thinking about his first name I don't think they'll be making a fuss the secondary alert has been lifted as well and the Soviets still haven't discovered my true identity they have no idea that I've been triple crossing them.
Triple crossing them!
But you...
I will continue my activities as a contact for the new government.
I saw that.
Yes.
It appears that no one knew that I was Adam.
Wow, wow, crazy.
Of course.
I'm always at the CIA's disposal.
Mr. Director.
Dumb, dumb, dumb!
No!
Whoa!
Like a boss, clear the game on any difficulty.
My title is Jack!
Oh no.
Jaguar.
Jag...
Such a fun game and a great remake too.
So thanks for letting us watch you freak out.
Thank you.
I took your advice.
Doki should be playing Delta soon.
I don't know if the brain rot will hit her, but you know, we'll see.
Humans killed four!
How?
Wait, how?
Wait, what does this mean?
Hold on.
I look it up.
NGS3.
I don't know how to say this name this this animal you guys apparently say it wrong it was eva you think it was no way unless it counts the four bosses
oh wait here we go beat the game with 50 or less continues 36 or more alerts and a hundred or less kills how many alerts did I have I'm one over
buy it oh it's 36 or more so two no way easy
I wonder what I would have got another was oh wait maybe uh no Because there's Leopard, which has beat the game with 51 or more continues.
Who's beating the game with 51 continues?
36 or more alerts or 100 or less people killed.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, she's...
Thank you.
Gonna have to watch the mod.
I hope you enjoyed the remake as much as it did the first time you played the original.
I'm assuming you played the original before.
No, I've never played it.
Wait...
Wait, I should have...
You guys...
I'm so upset right now.
There's a title leech.
And it's you beat the game with a leech attached to your body.
Title leech!
I think he got the same title you did.
Oh, yippee!
That means we got the same.
The face went, Vinky.
Yeah, we got the same.
Let's see.
I wonder what I would have had if my alert phase was down.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no.
Centipede, no.
That's 51 or more continues, but 35 or less alerts.
Chameleon beat the game with no alerts.
That's insane.
Huh.
Hmm.
What'd I get?
The Patriot.
Camera.
Green face paint.
Brown face paint.
Taxido!
Banana.
DPM.
OSCAM.
Desert Tiger.
Flectarn.
National flag face paints.
Mummy!
Grenade!
Yeah, the grenade camo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Reward camo.
Oh my gosh.
We can be...
What?
The hearts are so cute.
Demo theater!
Secret theater!
Guy Savage!
Character viewer.
Will they fall in love with me?
If I wear that?
Tear.
Ah.
Are there any new secret theater?
Apparently there are.
Hello, game.
Oh, there we go.
Um, I'm gonna have you guys listen to this and I'm gonna go get some more water.
Really hungry though.
We will watch some secret secret theater, but I don't know if I'll get the people.
I'm so sorry.
D'Orgo, thank you so much for the food, D'Orgo.
Thank you.
I'm just so hungry.
Then I have to go out and get food.
I don't know what I mean.
Um, just one second, I'm gonna go get water.
I'm searching and I'll melt into you.
What a fear in my heart But you're so supreme I give my love
My time
To you I'm still in a dream Snake eater
Someday you go through the rain And someday you feed on a tree frog This ordeal, the trial to survive For the day we see new life Not for honor, but for honor you.
In my time, there'll be no one else.
Crime, it's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream Snake ita
But I'm still When I dream Snake ita
Snake ita Snakea Oh no What the hell?
No!
This is so messed up!
Oh!
This is so messed up.
No horse.
No.
The 3DS version does this too?
No way.
Really?
I never beat the 3DS one, so...
You can hear him.
You can hear he's like...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We have this to do it.
It's okay.
Alright, let's do some...
Oh, that hurts.
Oh, that's what the question mark was for Guy...
I thought it was for Secret Theater, but it's for Guy Savage.
I kind of.
I think...
Well, people knew about it beforehand.
But then they also tweeted about it.
I wish they had kept it a secret.
So that...
So that the question mark would be like, Huh?
What's that for?
Secret theater!
Huh?
Wait, I thought it said all unlocked after the end of the game.
Wait, I still actually have to get them from everybody?
I still had to get the I would have actually...
I thought the whole thing unlocked once you made it.
No way!
They just meant the actual thing unlocked.
Not the actual thing.
No.
Oh, wait.
This still is the same, too.
This is so cute.
Wait, can we do sexy time with like...
Wait.
Stripping Rycom.
Wait, can we change it?
Can we change the sexy time?
Wait, why can't I do sexy time?
Ocelot wins.
Wait, where is the sexy time?
Maybe it's over here.
Where's sexy time?
Sexy time?
Where is it?
Where is sexy time?
Why is this one...
Why are some of these...
Some of these are locked.
I was on it.
No, not removing the transmitter, the very end of the game.
Oh, we could do this one.
We could do that one.
Where was that?
This one?
Wait, can I change the people?
Oh, it doesn't seem like it.
Dang.
Get me out of here.
Oh, dang.
There's still a new secret theater you can watch at the top.
Yeah, that's what I was about to do.
Oh, just kidding.
Let me out.
Okay.
We'll watch this one then.
Oh, my ears.
Oh, my gosh.
Keeps going through the same.
Door, what is this, PT?
So Secret Theater is a lot of fun because it just makes every cutscene silly.
So we'll see what silliness happens here.
I haven't seen any of the new Delta ones, so this is completely new for me.
Ship posting in 2004.
Why is Sokolov...
Wait, Sokolov is super saiyan?
Good work, Jack.
What are you doing here?
Sokolov comes with me.
I guess for these, they would have to have recorded new lines maybe.
As well.
So that's fun.
my friends my friends let us fight together again I have waited long for this day we will fight with you once more oh yeah welcome back boss now that all why doesn't fury say anything it's time we go to the depths of hell itself
He's too angry.
Alright, so we'll have the weird thing.
Oh my god.
No!
Do you think this one is a continuation of...
of the one where... Oh!
They didn't remake them.
That's so interesting!
They're the original cutscenes!
They didn't remake them, they just added them, which is so nice.
Do you think this is a sequel to the guy that didn't get his hands shaken?
Oh my gosh, I have to go find all of them.
Wait, which one is this?
one where his hand doesn't get it right cat-like behavior
the first three i knew yeah yeah yeah because it says it has like the delta symbol so yeah huh huh interesting
interesting that didn't huh okay it's
payback oh oh i see it it does look like it okay what if i just secret what if i just what if we just look them up what if i just youtube them
uh metal here metal gear solid delta secret theater let's see okay all new secret theater okay
Oh, no,
I'm getting spoiled.
Okay, one moment, please.
One moment.
Okay, this IGN.
Okay, hold on.
I have to...
We'll skip the first one.
Okay.
Wow, this is quite long, I think.
Unlocks after completing the story.
Okay.
is safe with us, Minto.
Thank you.
Okay, now I do window capture.
This one?
Uh.
Like that.
Okay, that should be good.
Oh, wait.
My bad.
There we go.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
That should be good.
fit the screen.
Okay, so this is the second one.
Oh, oh, I'm so sorry.
I just realized I didn't have the audio on.
Okay, one second.
There we go.
Oh, my ears.
I could have.
Sorry.
I got you.
So what's this part?
Wait, that's not Vulcan.
Who's walking in?
My god!
Gran and Ryzen!
You're the intruder everyone's talking about.
No!
He's, like, so messed up.
Oh, my God.
Who, uh...
Put that thing away.
You'll spoil my drink.
It's him.
Are they just splicing lines?
It's him you're looking for, isn't it?
What is happening?
I have been stripped of my authority.
My research has come to nothing.
Tank does not need a rocket.
It needs something else.
Legs.
What is happening?
Oh.
He just shot his legs.
Oh, we missed the nice shoes.
Oh.
This looks like a randomizer mod cutscene.
It does.
Oh, why did they shoot his legs?
You'll be killed.
Oh, my.
Legs that allow it to go anywhere.
Just as when humans learn to walk upright.
That is the real revolution in weaponry.
Don't you agree?
Oh, my God.
Listen to me, you fool.
What are you talking about?
This is so funny.
Put that thing away.
Spoil my drink.
It's like a real shit pose.
This feels like a YouTube poop where he just keeps saying legs.
You mean you've never heard of me?
And you call yourself an agent.
Very well, then.
It's so tough.
I am Alexander Leonovic Grady.
Are you going to kill him?
It is a revolutionary mobile nuclear missile system.
A bipedal tank.
Legs.
Hashtag legs.
Oh my gosh.
You know, she's thinking so much.
Yes.
A walking tank.
A robot.
This is the order of letter.
He's in honor of the greatest magnet you've been along with.
He's just talking in there, he's just yapping.
His voice is so quiet.
Why did she beat him up?
What is it going to do with a rocket engine or a tank?
This is so stupid.
The tank does not need a rocket.
Need something else.
Blanks.
Say the line.
Wait,
I didn't realize when...
When did Sokolov switch with...
With Snake?
Did we beat him?
Oh, no, wait.
Oh.
It's still granon.
Oh my god.
He feels like Armstrong.
You're the intruder.
Everyone's talking about you.
What is this?
This is a YouTube move.
Oh, he's beating up Sokolov because Sokolov designed the Shagohan without legs.
Oh my god.
He does not need a rocket.
It's surreal.
He's good.
I am Alexander Leonovich Guggen.
Okay, this one is good.
This one I saw a preview of already, just in the thumbnail, and I'm excited.
Okay, so this is the third cutscene.
Legs.
Lolliloo, low legs.
Lolliloo, legs.
Lolliloo, legs low.
Oh, shirtless.
I grabbed my new Ochi.
That was so good.
Wait, where are those gonna go?
You are above even the boss.
I hereby award you the title of Big Boss.
You are a true patriot.
This is sick.
He's grimacing.
Someone help my man.
Everyone else is also like,
Don't pow levels of dumb, you're so right.
This is actually so stupid.
Not this scene, though.
This is so terrible.
What is he...
He's like...
No, not another one.
No, no, no, no.
The sound effect is so terrible.
You know, a unit like Fox in the army.
Someone like him to handle our top secret sneaking missions for us.
It's so bad.
A man who combines the qualities of a soldier and an agent.
Can you forget to change your outfit before the cut's in?
No, no, don't do another one.
Okay, good.
No!
No.
Don't do it.
Paramedic, don't do it.
There's another one.
They're reusing that part.
With Tatiana.
What?
What the?
I am a patient man.
It was all just a dream.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's a leech on his teeth.
That's why he was having the bad dream.
Wait, there's another one?
Oh, this is still the same one.
Oh, no.
Whoa.
Does he not see the leech?
I think he likes it.
Wait, it just keeps going.
He came prepared with like actual battle armor so that he would.
This is something he would do.
This is so in character for him actually.
You are above even the boss.
No, he's scared!
Look at him!
Did you hear it drop to the ground?
That was good.
That was so silly.
That was so silly!
Oh my gosh!
They're just as good as the originals, honestly.
That's so funny.
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
This game is straight up art.
Oh, the three new ones are so good.
I'm obsessed with Grandin's being obsessed with legs.
I can't get over it.
It's so funny.
Oh, in front of the...
Oh, this is so sad.
This is so sad.
What is MGS even about, bro?
my gosh wait we get Eva ending oh my get off my bike when I fall in love or fall dead I love it whoa oh wait no keep the clay yeah there's the glasses look so good I love Eva and the glasses yeah baby so
cool I am the fury the flames of My rage will incinerate you.
So cool!
Why is your...
Okay, look at them.
Shagohad.
Nice.
One, two, three.
Sub-characters.
Oh, wow, you can even really...
You can look at their...
Rycom...
No!
Why from behind?
What you want to join me?
Fine then.
Come on in.
Someone in here.
Johnny.
Hold on.
Hey, you're not such a bad guy after all.
Even the horse.
Wait, is he gonna say that?
I am Alex, a kind of metal gear, if you will.
Legs.
Legs that allow it to go anywhere.
Just as humans learn to walk up.
right that is the real revolution in weaponry don't you agree i'm obsessed i'm obsessed with that one it's so funny yeah he really got no butt huh it's like concave even a little
oh oh this is so yeah my enemy is the scientists
I'm I'm shocked the mechanics didn't get me really at all this time no the flying platform guys here they are cute ah this is so fun I love little things like this
I just got here oh good heavens ah man well thank you guys for snake eater we will return to this game because there is still fox hunt to be played so we'll either play snake versus monkey before then or uh during then who knows but I know a little secret about snake versus monkey which is kind of of fun i'm very excited about it for those who don't know yet but it's very fun when does fox come out i believe it comes out october november the snake versus monkey opening cutscene i'll save it i'll save it
i'll save it i'll save it what is fox hunt it is multiplayer it's uh i guess well we'll learn more soon I think at TGS in a couple weeks but um but we can play together we can play if you guys have the game you'd be doing directional mic dot dot dot dot dot dot dot but yeah so we can kind of hide and seek it seems so why is everybody us a lot we can all be us a lot
and also at tokyo game show i believe the head director i don't remember his title i'm so sorry but one of the guys leading the master collection we'll be speaking as well so hopefully you will hear about master collection too in the multiplayer can we play as our beloved Oshi Granin?
I sure hope so.
But yeah.
So Fingies Crossed.
Fingies Crossed.
That we hear more about the Master Collection Volume 2.
And also that it has 4 in it.
I would really love for like...
Honestly, just the rest of the games.
Like 4.
I don't think they need to...
do five again but like acid, hoops you know everything.
I want everything.
Peace Walker?
Maybe I'm being greedy.
Imagine it would be four Peace Walker V.
Yeah, maybe.
We got Membu tomorrow!
Yeah!
Oh, we've done movie watchalongs the past couple of so I kind of want to do something else.
Well, we'll see.
Have you decided what you're going to do for stream tomorrow?
Nope.
I'll figure it out.
It's fine to be greedy.
Is it?
Be greedy?
Yeah.
Because already you can get V on Steam, so it feels kind of weird to release it.
But I guess maybe to have it on a different platform would be nice, too.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But this was fun.
This was so, so fun.
Whoa.
I thought I was like, I wonder if I'll cry.
And I still cry.
I cry every time.
Yeah, ghost babble.
The Game Boy games would be nice.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
listen okay i'm so hungry you guys i gotta go get something to eat i'm so sorry i wanted to do snake versus monkey but i'm so so i'm starving i've been starving since since shagohad fight so thank you so much for hanging out with me and watching with me and I can't wait we'll revisit the game later for all the other stuff as well so we're not quite done with Delta yet but we're done with the game and then maybe then too I could do the boss fight with CQC or something maybe I'll do that members or something thank you everybody bye bye bye